Live,
what's up?
What's up boys?
So nice to have you guys on man.
It's a nice first of all to a nice to
have you guys in studio,
but it's nice to have more tie,
which I've been a giant fan of for so
long.
I feel like it's starting to get more
ground in America and we've done our
best to try to promote it as much as
possible and here and it's been
frustrating for the longest time for me
watching what I think is like one of the
most exciting combat sports in the world
and it's sort of kind of slip under the
radar man when golf is taken off golf,
so everywhere they had a scrabble on
espn one time and that was just gut
wrenching.
That scrabble.
Well it is a sport so a lot of training
involved.
Hey man,
it's brutal.
But to see that and then to see us just
with nothing,
no coverage whatsoever for so long and
you know,
finally on tv but still relatively under
the radar.
It's tough to watch but you knowing that
it's going to be there eventually,
it's just a matter of time.
You know,
so it's nice every,
every time we take another step,
like when it got on access tv,
it was such a giant leap compared to
where it was prior to that.
So what,
what's coming next?
What's coming next?
It's just a matter of time and the right
people coming along and doing the right
things.
One can only hope it's when we talked
about this today,
but uh,
the Dana white had a point that I think
he's probably right about,
is that in a lot of people's eyes in
America,
kickboxing got poisoned with that old
pka karate stuff that was on and like
the eighties and the nineties put a bad
taste in people's mouth.
So it's hard to break free from that
mentality of you think kickboxing,
Muay Thai,
you think pants fighting?
Yeah,
I remember the shoes and everything.
Everybody thinks,
oh,
you do that thing with the pants and the
shoes.
I took a buddy of mine who was a,
uh,
he's a producer.
He was a producer of fear factor.
Actually my friend David,
I took him to some Moy Thai fights in
Burbank.
This is a local show that was at some
hotel,
you know,
they just had a ballroom and uh,
this was back when I'm God,
who the fuck was fighting on that card
and I'll,
I'll remember,
but some,
some good names,
some really good fighters.
This is like back in 2000,
one,
2002.
And uh,
he had never seen like Moitai before.
He really had no idea what to expect.
And he was like,
Oh,
when they kicked the legs,
it makes a big difference.
I was like,
yeah,
it makes a fucking huge difference.
Well,
every time you have to,
somebody asks you.
So it was more tight every I feel.
So I,
I really dislike when I have to say it's
like kickboxing with elbows and knees,
like I died a little bit inside every
time I have.
It's a matter of how long you want to
sit there and talk to this person
because you can be like,
no,
it's actually this,
this,
that.
And so sometimes it's like,
is it like fixed kickboxing?
Like,
yeah,
see you later with Ella was a nice.
You're late like well kick as hard to
explain it.
It looks the same when you're looking at
it.
Like if you're watching glory it looks
the same.
You know?
And then when people talk about like
I've,
I've had people over watching the fights
that go,
wait a minute,
this isn't Moitai well it's similar.
It's like on the door,
it's like the difference between
American football and rugby.
Like they're similar,
they're running,
there's a ball,
but they're not the same whatsoever.
The two,
they're two different sports that
dissimilar because it is really
completely because it's a completely
different pace.
It's a completely different mentality.
Yeah.
You're,
you're limited on a just a few weapons
which seems very minor,
but in an icu fight it,
unless you do it,
it's,
it's night and day.
It's night day.
Well,
I would imagine that it would make,
there was,
there'd be a big adjustment for people
that are listening that don't know what
we're talking about.
Kickboxing,
if you watch like glory or now Bella
tours having kickboxing as well,
and of course k one was really the first
one to start it on a global scale and
make these big gigantic events over in
Japan.
Kickboxing does not allow the use of
elbows or knees and the very limited
amount of clinching.
Yeah.
Whereas in Moitai,
especially in Thailand,
you see a tremendous amount of clinching
and it's very technical.
There's a lot going on in that clenching
and I've always maintained.
I've been a big fan of lion fight
because what lion fight is doing is
giving you the actual pure Moitai you
know,
other than the dancing and the music and
all this stuff that happens before,
you know,
in a traditional Moitai fight.
Yeah.
They're,
they're doing a really good job.
And,
and as you said,
they've had to a limit a few of the
things in order to get it out there to
the general public,
which it's unfortunate that you can't
just,
you can't just like throw it out there
and people's faces with all the culture
and the tradition is particularly here
in America,
you know,
people,
people turn away from it so fast.
So I think at some point we'll be able
to build up to that,
you know,
if you start slowly,
I'm educating people on what that is and
the history and everything and hopefully
eventually we won't get so far away from
that,
that does become kickboxing because
we've taken so much from it,
you know.
And for people who don't know what we're
talking about,
again,
the,
the dance that you do,
the warmup dance before a Moitai match
called why crew.
Right.
And how long does it usually take it?
It depends really.
Um,
you know,
different gyms,
a different people do,
do,
do longer and shorter ones.
You know,
I,
I do a very limited,
a shorter one,
a when I fight.
Well,
I haven't done it in forever but,
but because of that,
you know,
and knowing that people aren't,
don't want to really want to see it,
you know,
you kind of Americanize it and shorten
it where some of them.
I've seen some,
I've seen some longer.
Why Cruz and then fights in the past.
Yeah.
Well what's a long one?
Five minutes
kind of has like one of the longest ones
I've seen.
Like he takes his sweet time,
you know,
it goes down those everything like
perfectly.
It's like a,
it's like a whole routine.
But then in those situations like people
are very educated and they want to see
that they want to see the beauty of it
almost becomes part of the entertainment
part of the fight,
but besides the fight itself.
But when you go see a professional
Moitai match,
I would estimate that like 50 percent of
the crowd trains.
They're very educated in what it is.
You know,
it's like,
it's like baseball here in America where
you don't have to play baseball in order
to appreciate and love it because it's
our pastime and that's what it is in
Thailand.
Not,
not everyone there is actively training
or fighting or has fought,
but it's so embedded in their culture
that,
that they just love it and they
appreciate it.
Everything about it.
So to go to a live Muay Thai fight in
Thailand is just,
you can't even describe it.
I could only imagine it's on my bucket
list for sure,
but in America,
if you go to see a live event in
America,
half of the audience at least is either
people from the gym or people that know
people from the gym and it's sort of
almost an incestuous kind of an
environment.
Yeah.
Especially like when I was coming up,
the only people that were there trained
were family or friends of the people
fighting,
you know,
so that you weren't hitting this,
this wider audience,
you know,
where we are now.
It is getting on TV and there are people
seeing it who,
who don't know anything about it and
it's slowly building momentum and
getting out there and getting a little
more popular.
But it's just one of those sports where
you know,
it's,
it's not for everybody.
And,
and you gotta find the way to,
to bring it to everyone.
You know,
it's not,
it doesn't have this mass appeal.
The fight in itself does,
but,
but all,
everything that goes with it is very,
uh,
it's different.
It's very traditional.
The Thai style.
And then the music is very traditional
and it's,
it's for a lot of people,
for whatever reason,
they just don't have an open mind.
They don't want to accept that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's strange.
And like we were saying,
you know,
watching it live compared to watching it
on tv,
it's like two different things.
So yeah.
So yeah,
there's nothing like it.
Even for me,
I'll watch it on TV and then I'll be
there in person.
I'm like,
Geez man,
like why do people do this?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I do this.
Yeah.
It's sad,
but it's without any combat sport.
If you,
when you're there live,
you could feel it.
You feel the energy in the air,
you feel the impact as opposed to
watching it on TV,
which is still great,
but nothing compares to being there in
person,
particularly moved tie.
It's just brutal.
Yeah,
I agree in that it's,
there's something about it when you're
not hearing any commentary,
you just literally feeling the slap of
the shins bone to bone.
It just makes me cringe.
I was in la a couple of years back when
they had that big pro Moitai event.
They had a lot of big name fighters
fight and book how fought and he,
uh,
had some beef with some dude that he
was,
uh,
gonna fight and there was a lot of shit
talk back and forth.
So we had this long.
Why crew where he was shooting arrows at
them.
Remember that?
Yeah.
That was the NPL,
right?
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
What happened to that organization?
Same thing that happens to a lot of
organizations.
They,
they,
they try to go too hard out the gate.
They pay all this money for all these
super high level fighters,
which you know,
your,
your mood tie fans going to know who
they are,
but your,
your general public has no idea.
And that's who we're trying to reach is,
is the people that don't know anything
about it.
So those people aren't going to come out
just because there's a high level
multitech I,
they don't know who this is,
they don't anything about them.
They'd be more likely to come out to a,
uh,
a local person because at least I'm
like,
hey,
that guy flights out of California or
whatever.
And,
and that's
been the biggest thing that's a slow,
slow mo tie down is these promotions
tried to go too hard out the gate and as
opposed to building it up,
which you know,
you got to lose a lot of money and build
these people with anything.
You got to start slow and build people
gradually build a promotion,
build the fighter's,
build your audience,
and eventually you can get to that level
where,
where everyone in the card is like top
10 people.
But you can't do that from the beginning
when you were just trying to grow and
build.
Yeah.
I remember I went to the event and uh,
Larry Merchant was there,
remember the boxing guy,
Larry merchant was there.
A lot of people were there and
[inaudible] was doing commentary.
It was.
And I was like,
wow,
maybe this is going to work.
You know,
it seems like these guys have got it
too big,
too fast,
you know,
too many big names right away,
the rent,
I'm pretty sure they ran out of money
like by the second or third show,
it just didn't work out.
And that's where a lion fight has been
doing a really good job.
But like growing their talent and trying
to get better.
And like every shoe they,
they're putting really good fights and
really good match ups with guys from
around here.
Yeah.
Well the,
the match ups and the talent level is
very high.
It's way higher than the credit it's
getting.
Yeah.
It's like a watch.
I have a Dvr and my gym,
I've got,
I mean,
what,
what number they up to now,
like 30 something 30 to 32.
I've got way back to like 21 or
something just saved up and I can watch
them all while I train.
And it's um,
there's such high level.
There's so much good fights are.
So,
you know,
there's so many good guys.
It's so exciting.
And it's,
it's such a dynamic technical sport and
that's one of the things that I think is
probably,
it's probably,
it probably slips by some people when
the casual observers watching it.
Just some of the stuff that we were
doing today when you were showing me
just a little little shifts and
variations and stances and little things
like that.
And that's,
you know,
I think that's when you train in it or
you try it,
it makes the experience of watching
people compete in it richer because you,
you kind of understand,
you're like,
wow,
this is very complex.
There's a lot going on here.
It's not just guys going around and just
trying to fucking kick each other.
Yeah.
And there's so much.
There's so many levels to this and in
your casual fan isn't going to know that
in,
in a big problem a lot of promotions
make is they try to cut corners and put
guys out there who aren't very good.
But both those guys are at the same
level.
So for your average person,
they're like,
well,
they're kicking and punching each other
so.
But they might be very,
very low level,
but they just wanted to get some cheap
people they could put on the air,
you know,
so they'll,
they'll take all the cut,
all these corners just just to save some
money.
But at the end it hurts everybody
because you're putting crappy flights
out there,
you know what I mean?
Not good matchups,
not very talented guys because you want
to save some money or there they'll
spend so much money on like the main
event,
the main event that they have to cut
those corners with everybody else.
And so you're putting these crappy
fights out there in your brain trying to
bring this new audience in.
So people come and like this is
terrible.
Like why?
Why would I to come to this,
you know,
because because they're bad matchups.
And,
and as we were talking about line fight,
what they did from the beginning was
they had quality matchups throughout the
entire card.
Whether it was the main event,
whether it was undercard,
whether it was the amateurs,
they're good,
exciting matchups regardless of the
level.
And that's what really helped build them
up.
Now,
how long have you been fighting Moitai
now?
I started when I was 10 back in Lima,
Peru.
And how long have,
you know?
20.
Twenty four.
Yeah.
Um,
I think is really interesting.
You were telling me today we were
talking about your training partner,
a Missouri.
What's his first name was Gabriel.
Gabriel,
who's,
who just fought this past weekend and
lion fight.
You watch them fucking sensational.
Holy Shit.
Is that kid dynamic?
And his brother is like bigger,
older and like more even like more
aggressive.
That's incredible.
He's,
he's a lot there.
Yeah,
he was.
What was going on in Peru?
Like man,
my,
my first coach Rodrigo,
you know,
he,
he had a vision of the sport,
you know,
when,
when he first started he came here to
train with how he's gone from like San
Francisco and it was very small but he
went back and I remember I started
training with them and it was,
everything was so small back then,
like the amount of talent there is now.
Like,
I mean Kevin and Kerry inside when we
went to,
uh,
to Peru last November and hide in the
corner over there.
He's here but he's not here.
I mean there will be on cameras out on,
there was 150 fighters in the national
tournament last November when me and
Kevin were fighting and yeah,
it's crazy.
Like the amount of talent and how much
is growing.
I mean pro is definitely going to be a
powerhouse in the future.
Is it because of one coach?
Is it just as the country embraced it?
Is it taken off in popularity?
It's getting a little more popular.
But like I said,
Rodrigo really help help.
He,
he got to go with the government,
you know,
so they,
they can start helping mountain and
bring it guys out too if my and
everything.
And it's just crazy.
Like all these kits are really like 16,
17,
18,
19 years old,
really a kids.
So
it's just fascinating that that one part
of the world is starting to produce a
lot of,
like really high level talent and then
talking to you about it,
you know,
you were saying that it's like soccer
and then Moitai is like really like
coming up in popularity behind soccer,
which sounds crazy,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
and then our soccer team suck so
everybody's trying to turn to Moitai.
So it's really cool to see.
It's really cool to watch.
Watch
that is really fascinating.
You know,
more tie is the predominant striking art
in MMA,
you know,
it's the most,
uh,
I would say probably the most successful
striking art,
mma because it has all the elements of
boxing and uh,
you know,
a lot of the elements of a lot of the
other traditional martial arts.
But there's something about the
combination of kicks and elbows and
knees and the technical style of Moitai
that really lends itself to mma.
And I think when Maury Smith came along,
like Maury Smith was probably the first
guy who was like a really high level
technical striker who gave him a mayor
try and was showing everybody the
effectiveness of Thai
in mma,
but for whatever reason it never
translated to Moitai getting more
popular in mma,
but it didn't necessarily translate to
Moitai getting that much more popular.
Yeah.
It's one of those things that with the
mma it kind of helps and it hurts,
like it helps in the sense that it gets
it out there,
but it can hurt as well when,
when you're getting a bad representation
of the sport you do.
So.
So for a good stand up striker in MMA,
they might not be that great when it
comes to the tie,
you know,
so,
so you're saying,
hey,
this guy's got really great stand up
will.
He has really great standup for MMA.
So people assume that that's what good
standup looks like in a more tire,
traditional,
traditional stand up art,
you know.
So it's,
it's the,
the pros and cons of,
of it getting out there.
Um,
so it's stuff,
you know,
everything kind of helps as well as
takes away from the sport to,
well I think all martial arts make an
adjustment.
They have to make a technical adjustment
when they're being applied to mma
because you have to deal with the take
downs,
you have to deal with all the and even
wrestling and judo had to make
adjustments for more time because as
soon as you involve leg kicks and then
knees,
you know,
a lot of guys were shooting for take
downs and is going to need it.
They're getting into the face like that
Cyborg.
Um,
my mom,
uh,
Michael Page fight crazy knockout where
his whole head got crushed from that
knee surgery and everything.
Yeah,
I mean he's got literally had to have a
sculpture back together again.
It was the most brutal injuries I've
ever.
Have you ever seen one of those before?
Have you ever seen a skull get crushed?
No.
I actually had my skull fractured but
not like that.
That was the one of the worst things
I've ever seen.
How did your school?
I got kicked in the back of the head and
the guy had a steel plate in his Shin
Guard in China.
What?
Any shinguard yeah.
So we had a shin guard on,
with a steel plate in it.
Yeah.
I didn't really think anything of it at
the time,
you know,
this was like 10 years ago,
we would just fight all everywhere,
anywhere,
whatever,
you know,
and,
and not really think twice about it.
And I,
uh,
so I fought,
he kicked me in the back of the head.
I got dropped,
got up,
I ended up knocking him out,
fought again the very next day.
I'm Wyatt.
Yeah.
Not Knock this guy out to.
And then uh,
when we got back to the states I was
having headaches all the time and I just
thought I had a bad concussion,
you know,
but like up to like almost like a month
later I kept seeing these flashes of
light every,
anytime someone would ever touch me,
you know,
I'd be working with little kids or girls
and smaller people and just them
touching me.
I'd get this jolt and you know,
it was kind of freaking me out and I uh,
I was getting ready for another fight
and uh,
I had to get my Mri or a cat scan.
I don't remember what it was.
And he was like,
yeah,
you kind of inch and a half crack in the
back of your skull.
And they're like,
I don't know why you're not a vegetable
right now.
You should be there.
Like if you even hit that again,
you,
you'd probably kill you.
Doctors always say that though.
Yeah,
of course.
Was the last you were fucking
knocked out one more time.
I'm dead.
It was one inch closer to my spine.
I'd be dead.
It was,
it was,
it was pretty a rough thing to happen
into.
I couldn't do anything other than hit
the bag by myself for,
I don't remember how long it was to like
let it heal.
But,
but it was a toy just essentially how to
close on its own.
You don't get hit,
you don't get it.
And I was getting ready for a fight and
I actually still tried to fight anyway.
But uh,
that,
that doctor,
who doctor who diagnosed it was the
doctor for the fights.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Like,
dude,
he can't fight.
Get out of here.
How long after that was the fight?
After the diagnosis?
Like a week.
I said cat fight with fucking die.
That's,
that's just kind of the mentality I had
coming up,
you know.
And how old were you at the time?
Twenty five.
So he just felt invulnerable?
No,
not really.
I mean my,
my mentality from the beginning has
always been I'm going to fight as long
as I'm breathing and you know,
I've gotten into fights with some of the
worst injuries ever.
Broken hands,
broken,
broken skulls,
broken faces,
and that's just the way I came up,
you know,
like you're going to fight no matter
what,
you're going to fight anyone anywhere,
anytime,
any weight class.
And that's how I was able to get as much
experience as I did back there.
So,
you know,
good.
It's just,
it was the mentality we had coming up,
you know,
this was that time when,
youtube wasn't even out yet.
Like,
nobody knew what was.
It was like you gotta be ready to fight
all the time or else you're never going
to get any fights.
You know,
we're now,
it's like everyone's kind of like
looking for the big show or oh,
pick in there like a month,
like a month is short notice for people
were.
It was like an hour.
It was like,
yeah,
we're ready.
We're,
we're here to fight.
Let's go.
You know,
and it's just the time I came up was a
different mindset than it is today.
And that's kind of the pros and cons of
that.
Getting bigger is the bigger things get.
You got to take the kind of fake or
people with it.
Where,
where,
when,
when I started and I was at fights,
it's like you knew every person that was
at that fight was a die hard and we tie
fan.
There was no other reason to do this
other than the fact that you loved it.
You're losing money.
There was no,
there was no show to get on.
There was no television.
There was no reason to do this sport
except for the fact that you loved that
there wasn't,
wasn't a question like there's no reason
to do this except for you.
Love it with everything that's in you.
So everyone,
you met,
everyone you talked to,
every gym you went to,
every fight you went to,
you were surrounded by people that had
the same heart and mentality is you.
Whereas now you know,
people are doing it for different
reasons.
You know,
that they,
maybe they want to get famous or they
want to get instagram followers or you
know,
they want to look cool doing pad work
and that's kind of the good and the bad
of things getting bigger.
So you think that by the sport getting
more popular by more people paying
attention to it,
it opens up the door to more people
doing it,
but they just don't have the pure
intention of course.
And that kind of waters down the sport
at the end.
So it's interesting because there's got
to be,
there's a,
there's a line right between like where
it's intelligent to fight injured.
Like with your broken head.
I would never,
that would never tell anyone to do
today.
Would you think you would be in the same
situation today or would you go,
well,
what wisdom?
I'm not going to fight with me
personally,
but fortunately I have good people
around me who,
who would be like,
and that's not smart,
right?
I'm like,
yeah,
you're right.
And again,
it wasn't a time where if I don't take
this fight,
who knows?
One another fight is going to come along
and you know,
they're there.
You got to take what you can get when
you can get it.
And that's when I'm like fighting people
who outweighed me by 30 pounds and you
know,
just just taking a fight on a couple
hours notice because you got,
there was,
there wasn't opportunities so you've got
to do what you had to do to get in there
and he had to get experience and that
was the only way you were going to get
fights.
You know?
Was it difficult to motivate yourself
during those times?
Because for a lot of people,
motivation requires some sort of an end
goal or at least so much about.
It was more about getting fights and it
was about,
what am I getting out of this fight?
So it wasn't about making money,
it wasn't about getting on tv,
but,
but there was a long period of time when
I just couldn't get a fight to save my
life and that's when I was highly
considering switching over to mma
because everyone I trained was fighting.
They're fighting in the UFC there
getting fights all the time,
the fight and every month and I'm
sitting there busting my ass and I can
only get a fight or two a year.
You know,
I,
there was a time I had over 30 fights
fall through that I was training for and
preparing myself for it.
And then they'd fall through and they'd
fall through in the late fall through.
And that's why I started just taking a
boxing fight.
Even though I'd never trained boxing in
my life or taking a San shall fight that
that one in China was a sand shall fight
because I just had to do what I had to
do to stay busy or taking a flight on a
day's notice or fighting with a cracked
skull because I knew I had to stay in
there and stay active and stay busy or
else I'm never going to get better.
Especially if I want to compete with
guys who have like 400 fights and been
fighting since they were eight years
old.
You know?
How are you going to fight against the
guy like that?
If you don't get the experience,
you have so much to make up for it
anyway.
I didn't start till I was 23.
You know what I mean?
I'm so late to the game.
My mentality was always I'm always going
to be playing catch up no matter how
good I get,
I'm playing catch up and so I got to do
everything I can every way I can.
Maybe it wasn't the smartest thing,
but I wouldn't be where I am today if I
didn't take those risks and maybe take
those.
Not so smart fights,
but yeah,
there is a fine line between putting
yourself out there and being dangerous,
but I don't know where that line is.
Yeah,
I don't think anybody does.
Right.
So that for me it was all for everybody,
so I was always on that.
I'm like,
I'm just going to do it no matter what
because where do you draw the line?
You stub your toe and you're limping a
little bit or you're not fight.
I Dunno,
maybe,
but I'm going to do it.
Yeah.
Do you.
When you say you started at 23,
was that when you started competing as
the first time I stepped foot in the
gym.
You were 23.
No training at all in martial arts
before that.
What motivated you to get in there?
Well,
I.
The first time I ever saw him when we
tie it was like 94,
90,
94 and 96.
I went back when espn used to play them
late at night,
like the old school fights in hours.
I'd always thought about boxing and
doing some kind of fighting in.
But I always love martial arts,
you know,
and when I saw them I was like that's it
man,
cause cause every other kind of thing
with like kicking and knees was like
taekwondo or point point fighting and
not that real boxing style of,
of hardcore fighting,
you know.
So when I saw them once I was like,
if I'm going to do anything that's going
to be it,
um,
but unfortunately at that time I was too
busy living in Vegas and drinking myself
to death every day and party and you
know,
and it was never one of those serious
things.
And so I never,
I never told anybody about it.
I was never,
because I didn't even know how serious I
was because obviously I couldn't do what
it lived the way I was living in
compete.
So I knew that if I was ever going to do
this,
I would have to completely stop
drinking,
partying,
living the lifestyle I was living.
And I wasn't ready to give that up,
you know,
I wasn't ready to give up my friends and
lose all these people.
Not to say that I would,
but I knew that was a possibility.
Um,
and I only ever told one of my friends
about it.
His name was moe and um,
you know,
I always figured people would laugh at
me if I told them I want to be a fighter
one day.
If you knew me back then you probably
would have left him when he talking
about like,
you drink every single day,
all you do is party.
And I told him and to my surprise,
he didn't laugh at me at all.
He's like,
well,
why don't you,
why don't you go after it?
And I was like,
well,
I'm like,
I was only like 18 at the time.
And at that point I thought it was way
too old to start.
I'm like,
I can't start now.
I can't start now and make it anywhere.
You know what I mean?
These people are starving in there like
10.
It's too late for him.
And he's like,
you should do it anyway.
You know,
like if you want to do something you can
do it.
And He,
uh,
he was born with a bad heart and he
ended up passing away.
Um,
and I promised myself when he died that
I would do it.
I was like,
I'm going to go after this dream,
um,
if not for myself.
Then for him because he was never able
to,
to live,
you know,
and unfortunately his death sent me just
in a really bad downward spiral.
Even more so than I was already in
drinking and partying and all that
stuff.
And this continued on for years and
years and in through a month long series
of really horrible things happening,
like friends dying or almost killing
people,
drunk driving and myself getting pulled
over,
doing like 120 on the two slash 15 in
Vegas.
And for whatever reason the cop let me
go.
And,
and that was just the,
all these things happen.
And it was this huge wake up call for
me.
And I realized that if my friend was
still alive,
he would beat the shit out of me.
You know,
he's like,
well,
you're wasting your life.
You're wasting this dream you have
because you're too scared to do it.
His dream,
you mean you would never even stepped
foot in the door.
So this is like a dream of you one day
attempting to learn something,
right?
Yeah.
That's a very crazy thing because it was
always hanging over your head then.
Yeah.
And was again,
it
was that thing where I'm not going to be
able to get anywhere in this,
but I finally realized that where I get
to isn't what matters.
Like how good I can get doesn't matter
me giving myself all of myself to this
sport and dedicated myself to this is
what really matters.
How,
where I make it to,
I don't know where I could make it so I
can be the best in the world or the
worst in the world,
but as long as I'm putting myself out
there,
why is that more important?
Why is it,
why is the most thing important to put
everything you have into it?
I've just always believed that if you're
going to do something,
it's all or nothing,
you know?
Um,
I,
I never wanted to see half asset and
that's why I knew if I was going to do
this I'd have to give up partying and
drinking and hanging out with my friends
and going out all the time and I wasn't
ready to do that.
You know,
I,
I've always been in that mentality of if
you're going to do something,
do you do it all the way?
You don't do it at all because.
Because you're sabotaging yourself and
then you can just say,
oh I didn't make it because of this,
that and the other.
Right.
But why was it so what,
what were you getting out of it when
you,
when you realized that it wasn't really
about how good you get or how far you
go.
It was about giving it everything you
have it.
A lot of it had to do with seeing my
friend pass away it at 18,
you know,
I'm like,
there's no reason to ever halfway do
something because there's people who
don't get the opportunity to,
to even attempt to go after these things
because because of whatever reason they
might die,
they might have a disease,
they might,
you know,
not have all their legs,
and you,
you can do this.
Maybe you can't be the great,
but you can do this.
You can at least attempt this and you
owe it to yourself and you owe it to
them to give it everything that you
have.
I always felt like I owed him everything
to go after my life with everything.
I have all my dreams.
I need to go after 100 percent because
there's people that don't get to.
I'm asking this because I think this is
a common theme with people is that when
they're pursuing a dream or when they're
attempting to do something,
they realized somewhere along the line
that you're doing something more than
just like trying to get really good at
Moitai or,
or whatever.
You know,
fill in the blank with whatever sport it
is,
your eye.
I was the expression that was used as a
martial arts are a vehicle for
developing your human potential and I
think that until you have a really
difficult task in front of you,
like becoming a professional Moitai
fighter,
which is one of the most difficult tasks
and all combat sports,
until you have that task in front of
you,
until you go down that road and realize
how much is actually required of Hugo,
you don't know how much you can give to
something.
Right?
And once you do realize how much your
capable of giving you something and then
you can give a little more and then you
can give a little more than you realize.
Why did I give my all I did,
I did.
I watch what I ate.
Did I sleep enough?
Did I do,
did I think about things the right way?
Did I get anxious when I shouldn't have?
Did I that I keep my mind clean?
You know what?
What was I doing wrong?
What was I doing right?
How can I improve?
And then it sort of trickles over into
your life.
Yeah.
Well,
in the beginning,
as I said,
for me it's always been all or nothing.
You know,
I didn't realize that at the time,
but,
but looking back,
I can kind of understand the mentality
behind it is there's so many things that
are going to come up that will deter you
from going after.
Maybe you get injured or maybe you're
not getting the opportunities and if
you're not in it 100 percent,
those things are going to steer you
away.
Those things are going to make you quit.
It's that people kind of look at.
People have made it as if they just had
this easy path and all of a sudden
they're there.
They're in the spotlight and they're a
world champion and doing these things.
But it's like any person who's made it
to a high level,
whether it's an athlete or a
businessperson,
if you go back in their life and see the
things they've had to do and overcome
the obstacles in their way,
you have.
You have no idea.
And that's why everyone's like,
well,
they didn't have to deal with this or
they didn't have to deal with this.
You don't know what they had to deal
with.
You don't see the obstacles.
Isn't that always a problem when you do
something kind of condensed to one
performance?
You know,
like if you watch like Gabriel go out
the other night,
you look at him,
he's 19 years old.
He destroys that guy,
was the guy's name Josh a shepherd,
a shepherd who was a really talented
fighter herself,
goes out and destroys this guy in the
first round.
Like,
well,
how hard could he have worked?
He's fucking 19.
She was a young kid.
I was training.
I mean Karen and I were training that
kid and I was like running him to the
ground every single day.
I mean,
he's really good.
He's a really talented already.
But I was like,
you're,
you're in this position right now.
This is where you're going to do and
we're going to work really hard,
you know?
And I,
I dedicated myself to him throughout his
camp too.
I mean,
we're training together.
When I was fighting for my world title
fight and then he just kept training and
going and he's trained like three months
for that fight and that's why he looked
so good.
He dedicated everything to that.
Also super talented.
Also there's something about being 19,
right?
Right.
Isn't there something about being like
really what is it?
Is it a physical thing or is it a mental
thing?
Is it that you don't have as much
responsibility?
It's a combination of a lot of those
things.
Yeah,
without a doubt.
But it's,
it's super rare that a guy is like 35
and then how long is Gabriel been
training for?
He,
he wasn't even like,
he wasn't even that good at before.
Like he was okay.
He was good but like his,
he didn't get back until he went to
Thailand and he started taking like
really tough fights.
Even training for him since he was like
13.
I think.
So think of that.
That's only six years.
Yeah.
So it's very rare that a guy will be
like 34 and then at when he's 39,
he's this motherfucker have
motherfuckers like he is,
you know what I mean?
Like what is it?
Is it.
I've always wondered like is it that
life just you burden yourself down with
responsibility and information and just
life itself.
Relationships,
bills,
bullshit.
Just dress existential angst.
The,
the fucking,
the grave calling know there's,
there's so many variables that you can't
really like pinpointed on one specific
thing.
You know,
everybody in everybody's variables are
going to be different.
You know,
we're all,
we all have different things to overcome
and deal with.
Just because I've used yours is maybe
they're not that difficult.
Like you don't know.
I don't know.
Everything he's dealing with.
He doesn't know everything I'm dealing
with or have had to overcome.
But,
but if I sat there and listened to his
story,
I'm like,
Jeez.
Like I wouldn't want to do that.
I'm sure it's a crazy story.
But like when you go back and watch Mike
Tyson when he was 19,
you go see Mike Tyson,
like hitting the bag with teddy atlas
when he's 19.
Just go Jesus fucking Christ.
How does anybody get that good.
Like what,
what happens from 13 to 19?
how is it possible that someone can just
reach that insane level and it seems
that it happens primarily when someone's
really young.
Yeah,
I mean I started when I was 10 and when
I was 16.
And you can ask Karen like I felt
invincible,
man.
Like I will,
I will take much.
Uh,
Kevin,
I will take any fight,
any it didn't matter,
you know?
Um,
I was 16.
I couldn't fight as an adult yet because
I wasn't 18,
but we lied and said that I was 18.
And so because I ran out of people to
fight,
I ran,
I ran out of juniors to fight.
So from 16 to 18 I was technically an
adult and I was just taking this many
fights at anywhere from 132 pounds to
147.
Any fight that I could possibly take us,
I needed to get the experience and
that's what I wanted to do.
I wanted to dedicate my life to it.
Do you think that that's possible for an
older person?
Like so like Kevin,
you are.
You obviously you were still young.
You're 23 mean you're saying you were
older,
but a lot of people listening to God 23,
you're still like a baby.
You can still learn a lot.
I mean relatively though for the sport.
Kevin was old and I'll have people come
up to me like,
oh,
I'm too old.
I'm like,
how old are you?
Like 19.
I'm like,
dude,
like I didn't even start till I was 23.
What are you talking about?
Because people just.
I think people just like to view things
as an excuse,
like,
oh,
I can't do it because x,
but we all have something that we can
point to and be like,
well I can't make it because of this.
Of course,
but.
But there's people who have had that and
worse and have made it so what excuse
could you possibly have?
You are a very technical fighter,
you're very technical guy.
Do you think that maybe there is some
benefit in having started a little bit
later,
be 100 percent that,
that I think that's a huge thing,
um,
that just because you start,
you know,
when you start,
when you're a kid,
there's so much of it,
like you're just doing it and for
whatever,
but put once you,
you've,
you've
matured in a certain way.
Like,
like I started to for only one reason.
I want to be the best I can be on,
you know,
I'm,
I'm developed enough physically and
mentally to apply these things to,
to,
to what I'm trying to apply them to be
the best fighter I can.
Whereas yeah,
when you're younger you're still,
you're still growing and learning and
developing physically as well as
mentally.
Yeah,
like when I,
when I,
my first fight I was 11,
10,
like I didn't know why,
what I was doing there,
I just knew like I,
I kinda liked it but I like,
I didn't have like a purpose to it.
Like I just really enjoyed training at
the time.
It was exciting.
You
want to try them out?
Yeah,
I did,
but I wasn't like,
Oh,
I'm going to be the best in the world
right now.
Like they didn't come to like 14,
15 when I was like,
I really,
I really want to dedicate my life to
know where you were living in America at
the time.
No,
I was in Peru.
When did you come to America?
When I was 13.
When you were 13 years,
did you go straight to CSA?
Was it the first year?
I started a for text and then when I was
16.
Oh,
2008.
I met Karen and ever since we've been
inseparable would you guys have a very
unique gem and it's one of the most
important things for a young fighter is
to find the right environment to
develop.
And we were talking about that earlier
today.
Like you can get unlucky and find a bad
coach in a bad gym and you get all
tangled up with that person
psychologically and they become family
and then you know,
you're,
you're kind of fucked and it's a very
difficult break for a lot of fighters to
make.
Yeah,
man.
I mean,
like I honestly,
I,
I've been truly blessed since I started
all the way to now because I started
with Rodrigo then I was with son of
somebody who Kevin still trains with
this day to this day a little bit.
But you know,
I've,
I've always had really good coaching
since I started.
Yeah.
I think another,
another unfortunate thing is just
because somebody is a great coach
doesn't mean they're great for you.
You know,
so.
So sometimes you'll see these people
like leave their camps and go to this
really high level coach who's had a lot
of success with certain individuals,
but that doesn't mean they're going to
be great for you.
So I try to always tell people,
you have to find what works best for
you.
Whether it's a coach,
whether it's your diet,
whether it's your training scheduled.
What works for me won't always work for
you.
You got to find what's best for you and
that doesn't always necessarily mean I
need this great coach because you guys
might just clash.
You know what I'm saying?
Like like coaches and fighting.
It's very much about.
It's like having a relationship with
somebody.
Oh,
with another person.
Like you just might clash together,
not work and it's also how will you just
said is super important about finding
that winning formula,
whether it's training,
whether it's Diet,
whether it's coaching,
and then Jim partners like,
I know you guys are fantastic partners.
You guys work together really well.
I've watched a lot of videos that you
guys trained together.
I mean,
how critical is that to have someone
who's an elite fighter that trains with
you on a daily basis and it's on the
most most important things.
They're there.
There's so many factors that go into
building a fighter.
It's not just one thing.
You know what I mean?
And,
and that one thing needs to constantly
be adjusted because the way I trained
today isn't how I trained even a year
ago.
You continually need to be hopping back
and forth on this line of too much in
too little of one point.
The difference between how you train
today versus how you turn a year ago.
Uh,
I'd say I'd say the older I get,
the more it's a mental approach kind of
thing.
You know,
like,
like my technique in the [inaudible]
isn't going to be altered that much at
this stage.
But the way that I apply them,
the way I go about them,
the way I think about them,
it very much is gonna Change.
You know,
at a certain stage you,
it's like you
have all these weapons to use.
It's just a matter of which ones you use
at which time,
at which speed,
in the way that you apply them,
where in the beginning you're just
trying to do things well and you're
trying to almost put all these tools in
the toolbox,
you know,
as your career develops,
but better at a certain stage.
Not to say I'm not adding more is that I
have all these tools.
I need to figure out how,
which ones work best for me and which
ones work worked for me at which time
against which opponent,
which,
which venue,
which sport.
You know what I mean?
There's,
there's so many things that you can play
with and adjust and good and bad.
I,
that was a huge thing I struggled with
after my knee surgery was like almost
forgot how to fight as myself,
you know what I mean?
Because it was like,
okay,
here's all your weapons.
Pick up which ones you want to use.
I'm like,
I don't know.
I don't remember which ones I used in,
how I put them together and it took me a
series of fights to find myself again as
a fighter in the ring.
How much time did you take off because
you need surgery?
Nine weeks.
Nine months.
In one week.
That was between fights.
That was between the day I blew my knee
out and the day I got back in the ring.
Um.
You had acl reconstruction?
Yeah.
Throw me an ACO.
Which way did they do it?
A cadaver?
Yeah,
I had that way.
I just talked to a friend of mine,
she had it done.
They took a,
she was an Austrian,
a skiing accident and they took some
meat out of her calf I've never even
heard of before and reconstructed it,
you know,
there was those options,
but I was like,
I don't want to take anything else out
of myself into it might weaken that
thing.
Like I got enough to deal with now I
can't weekend something else.
So for me it was an in and talking to
other athletes that have had it,
it just,
it seemed like the better approach for
me and,
and,
and it has worked best for me.
It worked best for me too.
I had both knees reconstructed.
I had my left one done with the Patella
tendon graft with.
They take a big chunk on your patella
tendon with a piece of bone from your
Shin and a piece of bone from your knee
and it's fine.
But that was like a year before it felt
good again.
But the right knee,
like I have zero problems with it.
And I was training.
I was doing Jujitsu again in six months.
So it was,
it,
and it was with no pain,
like it never really,
like,
there was no consequences for the
injury.
Whereas the left one still like where
they cut the bone out.
Like if I kneel down on a hardwood
floor,
I could still feel it.
It's um,
there's a lot of people that are scared
of cadavers though.
They're scared her
weird.
Like for me,
it was more of a mentally a strange
thing,
you know,
to,
to have something of someone else's who
passed away and you know,
that was a,
just a weird,
very weird thing mentally to,
to kind of deal with.
And you know how it works,
right?
It's just a scaffolding.
No,
no,
not really.
No.
Um,
what it is,
is they take,
usually they use,
um,
an achilles tendon because it's much
stronger.
It's actually 150 percent,
I believe,
stronger than the original acl.
They take that Achilles tendon,
they put it in place,
and then your body re proliferates that
tendon with its own tissue.
Right?
So that tendon is not
there anymore.
Your body fills it up with cells because
they reattached the blood supply and as
your body starts it starts using that to
regenerate tissue so it puts your own
cells,
but in the form of a much larger tendon,
it's really kind of interesting.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
My my right leg,
which is the one that blew off,
feels so much better than my left one
does like stronger and looks thick and
they use a thick ass fucking tent.
I mean we have a shitty design.
The human body that acl in particular,
I'm just going to get everything
replaced.
Well,
as soon as you figure out heal hooks,
as soon as people figured out he looks,
he just realized like,
oh my God,
my knee is like so stupid.
Who figured that?
Who designed this?
Because all you have to do is get that
heel here and like,
pop just pops off.
It's terrible.
You know?
I mean,
it happens all the time and Jujitsu guys
get their knees blown apart.
That gives me nightmares,
man.
Just watching that.
Yeah.
Well it's.
I mean some guys get nightmares.
They watch you guys kick each other.
I know I've blown up a couple acl is
kicking people.
Yeah,
I'm sure didn't feel good,
man.
God,
was it a planted leg?
Is that what it is?
Most of the Times.
A couple of tough guys.
I tried to come in the gym,
go on and on.
I'm like,
alright man,
let's go.
Oh,
that's why.
That's why a lot of people like learning
how to absorb and take up a punch or a
kick is just as if not more important
than than throwing it because you're
going to get hit.
Sure.
No matter how good you are,
you're going to get hit and if you don't
know how to take that and absorb it and
minimize the damage,
you're going to have a lot of really
serious injuries and,
and,
and unfortunately so much of what we do
is applied to the offensive side of it.
Hitting people,
you know,
and those kinds of things.
But if you don't have to take a punch
and it wasn't,
obviously you don't want to just be
like,
all right,
I want to learn how to take punches
really good.
But.
But that's,
that's a skill that you need to have.
Yeah.
There's a subtlety to it that I think is
lost on a lot of people.
The ability to just move with something
and the way I was trying to tell people
like,
have someone hold their hand up and you
punch it.
Then have them move the hand just a
little bit.
Yeah.
And you still try to punch you,
but it doesn't feel good.
Yeah.
You know,
like it feels good when they meet you.
That's like,
people hold pads and they slap you with
the,
you know,
it feels good,
you hit it.
But if,
if,
if someone just kind of pulls away a
little bit,
so much of the punch is diminished.
Yeah.
No,
it really just drain the life out of you
because you feel like you're giving
someone all you have in,
in,
in your mind,
you're hitting them.
But nothing is happening.
And we have the winning a big shield,
you know,
and can we use it sometimes to train us
like towards the end of camp and it's
awful because you're giving everything,
you got to this thing and it's just so
fat.
Yeah.
There's nothing coming back at you.
So there's no,
there's no reverb off your head.
It's like you're punching into a cloud
and like,
oh gosh,
well I've seen some gyms that have that
crazy 300 pound bag that just sits on
the ground.
It doesn't even swing,
it just sits there and you wind up
kicking that thing.
And I'm always like,
man,
I don't know like that.
Is that good?
Is it good to,
doesn't.
It's another one of those things where
it's just a piece of the puzzle,
like it's good to,
to uh,
develop your power and stuff.
But yeah,
if that's all you're doing,
when something's moving around on you,
it's giving you very different looks.
It's kind of like a,
um,
like we do a lot of technical sparring,
you know,
with no gear on and stuff.
If you have these all these pads on and
you have this false sense of security
and then you get in there with someone
who's got nothing on and it's just like
feels,
feels almost your elbows and you're
messing your feet up because you haven't
learned how to place things correctly
and where they need to go and where you,
where you maximize their damage and
minimize yours.
Is there a point of diminishing returns
though with a heavy bag were like a 300
pound bag and you're kicking it.
It's probably not developing your power
as much as even maybe a hundred 50 pound
bag.
Would that make sense?
I guess it just depends on what it is
you're trying to do and work on it and
improve.
You know what I mean?
When you're hitting one of those
immobile bags,
what?
What would you concentrate on?
Primarily?
Power power is just dig in.
Just digging in as hard as you can
because I know that's going to be right
there.
I can close my eyes and hit this as hard
as I want to.
I don't know.
I don't have to worry so much about like
my balance and my speed,
I can just blindly do this kind of
thing.
So just dig in and work on just the
explosion.
Yeah,
but is there,
isn't there some benefit in the bag
having some sort of a give so the year
without pushing,
without a doubt.
Like I mean a lot of times when I'm
working on a speed and movement and
stuff,
I don't really just try to like crack
the back.
I'm just like touching his soul,
work on a much lighter bag and I'm just
trying to work on my ankles and in the
bag moving and targeting and those kinds
of things.
But again,
it's very specific in what I'm trying to
do and there's not just one way to do
this and.
And then I think that's another thing
that not a lot of people think about or
or applies.
She was like,
Oh,
I'm just gonna hit pads on.
I'm just going to hit the bag,
but why you're doing it?
What it is it that you're working on?
What are you trying to develop?
Because there's so many aspects to this,
you know what I mean?
And it's something,
but it's another thing that you just
figure out over time.
Do you remember when the water bags
were?
Big Deal?
Yeah.
It's like a big thing with those.
Like there was a thick foam outer layer.
Then there was water in it that didn't
really catch on.
We have an aqua bag.
It's a little different.
It's a little thicker.
Like rubber.
It's good for power punching.
I like it.
Throw elbows because he gives in on you
a little bit.
I mean,
not that it's very,
it's very well put together so it
doesn't like given as much as you think
it what?
Yeah.
What,
what are the misconceptions that you
think maybe even traditional martial
artists might have when they're looking
at Moitai?
Like what?
Maybe that it's really one dimensional.
You know,
I think,
I think we have this kind of like,
we think about it like,
like almost like the uh,
uh,
who was in a street fighter a real right
now the uh,
saget old school,
the old school,
a boxer.
When you think
about Muay Thai fighters,
just being this mindless,
like we're just gonna throw power at
each other and just stand there and we
have no thought process behind anything
and yeah,
there's definitely fighters who do that
and,
and maybe to an outside observer that
they might not see all the small details
and the complexity of the things they're
doing.
Just because I'm standing in front of
you,
not moving doesn't mean there's no
thought behind it.
You know what I mean?
It's like I've learned how to use those
head movement and footwork things on a
very,
very small scale,
you know.
So to me I am.
I am doing a lot of movement and
footwork but,
but to an outside person and I'm just
standing there mindlessly just winging
shots at each other,
you know,
so you don't see,
you don't see the,
all the complexity that goes into it
where I can watch it and view those
things very well.
Is it one of those things where you're,
you're watching like say,
um,
if you're watching an mma fight for
example,
where a lot of times when you're
watching mma you're watching someone
who's pretty good at a bunch of
different things but not maybe
technically proficient at any of those
things and you,
you,
you're seeing a lot of that where guys
are just kind of standing in front of
each other and almost playing Moitai
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
And as a high level fighter,
do you guys watch mma and go fucking,
oh my God.
I mean honestly,
especially the,
it hits me really hard sometimes.
Like when we're like Friday night lion
fights where they're alive and then
you're like watching whatever you have c
or whatever,
whatever the car there is on and you're
like on TV.
And he's like,
oh my God,
you know,
so.
But there is,
there is some good strikers in mma.
Sure.
There's guys like Barboza,
there's some pretty high level guys,
but Joanna,
sure,
sure.
Valentina Shevchenko.
Yeah.
But there's also a lot of different
elements they have to think about take
downs and it's definitely,
like we were talking about earlier,
you got to implement,
you know,
what works for you and mma.
So what,
what works for you might not work for
somebody else either.
So it's,
it's really,
it's really tough.
It's different now.
You at 24 years old,
you've already have a very successful
Moitai career.
Have you thought about doing her name?
Man?
So actually I just signed a deal with
belt or oh,
I'm sure I'm making the transition.
Uh,
not only with mma I wanted to do Moitai
keep doing more tie with lion fight,
but that has,
that,
that hasn't worked out so good.
So I'm going to be doing kickboxing and
MMA.
So that worked out.
Uh,
I,
they're,
they're going the different route so
it's not gonna work to promote and then
they fight or you know,
through what lion fight.
So Scott Coker is gonna,
you know,
has signed me in that.
He's going to be able to work both
angles with me.
So that's gonna.
That's gonna be really good.
Now you're a guy who clenches a lot and
uh,
that'd be great thing for mma,
but what about for kickboxing?
Are you going to do bell to our
kickboxing as well because I know that
bell towards doing a really interesting
thing right now.
They're kind of combining kickboxing and
mma on the same card.
Has Anybody talked to them about
abandoning the kickboxing aspect and
just doing moy,
Tai,
I don't know.
I'm,
I've said some things to Scott about it
and I think they're just trying to
establish that a,
that kickboxing side of their,
uh,
of their cards and uh,
hopefully one day he might bring in some
fights,
maybe,
maybe once,
once the belt or kickboxing can be more
of a standalone promotion.
I think,
uh,
it might be able to venture out into
mixing the cars and maybe have some
fights on the owner corridor in between
fights as well.
So,
but,
but for now I think they're just trying
to,
to start out and do things right and
build up that,
that portion of it and having those
mixed cards where it's the uh,
built or in my me and the bill or
kickboxing,
which has worked out very well and I
think people really enjoy it because
we're,
we're having both,
both fights on the card,
but eventually I'd be nice if,
uh,
the kickboxing can stand alone and then
kind of developed from there.
Yeah.
Just seems to me that it doesn't make
any sense to eliminate elbows and knees
just,
it seemed kind of crazy.
But again,
it's,
it's a different sport,
you know what I mean?
It is,
but it's striking,
you know what I mean?
I mean if you're,
if you're kicking like,
why aren't you elbowing?
Like why don't you need.
I can say I agree with you.
It's a beautiful.
I mean I think the more complex striking
gets,
the more beautiful it is.
I mean,
the more variables that exist.
Like when I watch a guy like Sanchez,
perfect example,
because he's such a wild guy to watch,
he's so he fights his own very
particular style and he's very light on
his feet as a lot of switching of the
feet.
A lot of kicks that you,
you,
you don't know where they're going to
think they're going low and they kind of
come straight up and go,
hi Kevin Fault.
Sanjay,
did you,
when you play,
when was that standard?
11,
2012.
Eleven or 12?
I forget.
August 2012.
It was right before you moved to CSA?
Yeah,
no,
I thought Saginaw before
the CSA.
How was that?
How was fighting?
I like,
I'll watch it,
man.
It was,
it was amazing.
So it was a great fight.
It's hard to describe what it was like,
man,
it was.
I was so dialed in physically and
mentally that,
that I've looked back on it.
I'm like,
Jeez Dude.
Like I can't believe I.
That was me.
And they're doing that.
Oh,
it was just so like I was in another
mental plane,
you know what I mean?
Like just everything was just firing
right here.
Okay.
We'll watch a little bit of this while
we're talking.
We have it in the.
I want you to see.
I want you to see looks after the fight.
So Cecil people's as a referee.
Yeah.
He kinda did it.
Oh yeah.
Who saw that comment?
Did he do that thing where he lifts his
knee up and does the karate thing at the
beginning?
I got to watch that.
That shit's hilarious.
How did he become the person to see
people's is a very nice guy.
I will say that.
I want to be a nice.
I want to see this high.
Ah,
there it goes.
The take that he does
that weird,
neat thing that he does,
but yeah,
Sanchez,
one of those guys like you.
He doesn't fight like a traditional Thai
fighter.
He's the best fighter of all time.
Arguably.
You know,
he's certainly one of them.
He's,
he uses so many things from different,
different arts and taekwondo and Moy
Thai and kickboxing and yeah,
he's got really sneaky left leg to man
that left leg.
It literally comes straight up and it's
one that you have no idea where it's
going.
It might be a front kick,
leg kick,
body kick,
head kick.
Like I knew he was going to kick me.
I just didn't aware of the hell it was
going well.
He's really good.
If you ever seen Lawrence tensions
breakdowns of Muay Thai fights,
um,
what is,
what is the name of them on Youtube?
I don't know what to see if you can
find.
I've seen one guys deal with a lot of
breakdowns in there.
Really.
Well I don't know if it's the same.
I think Lawrence just does them under
his name,
but he's a,
he's really,
really smart guy and really,
really aware of,
uh,
of more Thai and really aware of the
complexities.
And he did a breakdown on San shy and
one of the things Sanchez setting up
high kicks and the way he,
he'll sort of test you with some other
kicks and then he's got that really
unusual way of throwing his kicks to
where they literally come straight up.
Yeah,
there it is.
But let's go back to that fight.
I want to go back to that fight.
I don't want you to change some of that
guys and that's Kinda what we were
speaking of earlier in the gym is it's
just that one thing he's kicked butt,
but he has so many ways and variables to
set that up as far as speed.
And so he uses all these things to test
you and once he figures that out,
you're done.
And that's how he's able to destroy
basically everyone at every level of the
sport because he has so many answers to
that one question.
You beat him,
didn't you know,
it was a split decision,
split decision.
Why did I feel it?
Well,
Kieran saying you want some people think
that if I didn't get dropped but not
really dropped one.
Oh,
Cecil commercials got you with a bad
count.
Well,
it was a split,
right?
Yeah,
it was.
Or uh,
uh,
it's,
it's kind of ironic having cecil peoples
be the referee in a fight.
It's a Moitai fight because he's a
people's is one of those guys that says
that you can't stop people with leg
kicks.
That was like one of his quotes.
It was one of the bad decisions that
went down where he's like,
leg kicks,
don't stop.
Fights went,
oh my God,
were you allowed?
The thing about fighting is you have
people regulating these arts who have no
idea about them whatsoever.
Well,
that's a giant issue with the UFC.
That's a giant issue with judging and I
would imagine with tie it's even more
difficult to find competent judges and
you can't,
you're getting,
you're getting boxing judges doing,
you're getting karate guys doing a
Moitai and these are the people who are
basically controlling the outcomes of
these fights if there's no stoppage.
Right?
And it,
it,
it's,
it's crazy.
It's crazy in Thailand.
Wow.
That fucking sneaky.
Left leg.
He's got man in Thailand.
Um,
what,
how do they approach the clench because
you've seen in this fight like cecil is
breaking guys up almost immediately.
As soon as you tie up.
It's,
it's,
it's such a complex thing to,
you know,
it's not just the fact.
Are these guys working well?
What are they doing?
If you don't have a deep understanding
of it,
you're not going to be able to to a
judge it or ref it accurately.
You know what I mean?
So it's not just a matter of time is
it's not a matter of people moving
around.
It's what are they doing?
Are they affecting each other?
Are they hurting each other or they just
mindlessly like lifting your legs up to
appear to stay busy.
Where if somebody doesn't know that me
just lifting my leg up and be like,
oh well he's staying busy,
he's active,
why are they breaking them up?
But I wasn't really doing anything.
I was just screwing like a lot of times
they're like,
oh,
I'm going to let you guys work in the
clench,
but they just let like you're not doing
anything and they just let it go and not
not knowing when people are stalling out
or trying to buy time or just just
moving their legs for the sake of
looking like they're actually needing
each other and the and these judges in
these reps don't have an understanding
of that.
That's an issue with ground fighting as
well.
It's an issue of course the UFC,
when certain fights go to the ground,
whether it's judging or whether it's
even refereeing like some guys are
setting up certain positions and then
the referee will come up and stand them
up like that is crazy.
Like this guys,
they're working,
they're fighting,
but I think that in a clinch as well,
there's a lot of times they separate
guides from the clench when two guys,
if they're clenching up and they're both
working to try to establish dominant
positions,
one is eventually maybe going to win
that dominant position battle and that's
part of the grind.
Part of the grind is a guy in posing
your skillset as well as conditioning
all the above on his opponent and if you
just get in and separate that because
you want to watch a knockout.
Yeah,
you're kind of diluting the sport and
it's like,
I don't care how much,
how many fights you've watched or how
many courses you've taken.
If you haven't done this before,
if you've never fought before,
you don't know what's going on in there
and that's.
That's the problem.
You have people,
even if they've been in the sport for a
very long time,
it may have been around it for a very
long time.
If you've never fought,
at least at some level,
you don't know what's going on and yeah,
you're seeing it,
but you really don't know what you're
saying right there.
You don't know how much of it is
actually effective and how much of it
the guys that actually just absorbing
things and blocking things.
It's very.
It's,
it's so complex and I think that's one
of the things that gets lost about
fighting arts in general,
but more tie in particular is all of the
complexity that goes on.
Like what you were saying that a lot of
people that misconception is that they
look at it.
Two guys that are just bruisers yeah,
but what I'm watching here,
I'm watching all this complex
interactions of footwork kicks and
elbows and knees and clenching and and
knowing when to time things and dealing
with a really high level opponent is
very crafty and he's.
He's sort of calculating all this stuff
in his head as well.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's kind of the problem with,
there's only so much you can learn from
a book.
There's only so much you can learn from
watching videos until you apply those
things.
It's like
street smart and book smart.
If you don't have that street knowledge,
your,
your knowledge is very limited,
you know,
and,
and so I don't care how much you think,
you know,
if you've never applied it even or even
giving them just like sparring.
I don't care how much you spar,
you know,
until you get in there,
you don't know what it's like
management.
Yeah.
You know,
I think that's the case with a lot of
things.
I mean I even joke about golf because I
think golf is stupid,
but I get the people that do it a lot to
them it must be complex,
like they must understand all the
different aspects of it.
And I say that about playing pool to
that.
It's an art form.
It's only interesting for people to do
it and I think that's one of the things
that's cool about going to like what I'm
seeing here,
this is a small arena or small crowd who
you mean it looks like there's only like
four or 500 people and that whole place
and so that kind of shit.
I mean you look here,
here's you world championship caliber
fighter fighting another world
championship caliber fighter.
Both guys in their prime and you
fighting in front of 50 people,
you know,
and,
but it's been a couple of books and it's
super complex.
I mean what's going on is,
you know,
this exchange,
the interactions and I think one of the
things about having guys like Lawrence
Kenshin putting out these videos and a
lot of other people that have done these
tremendous breakdown videos with Moitai
is that people that are fans mean even
if they don't train themselves,
even if they just watch it,
they can see things now that it may be
perhaps they wouldn't have seen before.
And then appreciate what these athletes
are doing.
Like there's a lot of people that watch
football.
They can't fucking play football at all,
but they can enjoy it and I think that
you're seeing that in this,
you know,
and watching the flow.
There's a.
is that where he called a knockdown?
Yeah.
So he got right back up.
I mean why was that a knock down?
Because he got kicked in the head,
shoulder carrying.
If you want to talk,
you've got to talk on the mic.
Okay.
Look,
motherfucker,
I told you you were going to be on the
show.
Why don't you.
Why don't you get a Goddamn chair?
Because Jamie was still on the
microphone.
No,
this is the one thing.
This one thing that's lost that hasn't
been discussed is because Kevin doesn't
talk about it,
is to this day and how long ago was this
fight for years.
Four years ago.
To this day,
this is the only time that the WBC has
ever sanctioned at diamond belt fight
for a Moitai fight.
Was that mean?
What it means is that in boxing,
when you have two great fighters from
two different weight classes that meet
at a catch weight,
they make it a diamond belt fight and
they put a real diamonds on the belt and
it's the epitome of the WBC title.
Okay?
That's the only time in the history of
the sport.
The WBC made a diamond belt for a Moitai
fight.
That's what a watershed moment this
fight was for Moitai in America.
Okay.
Go sit down.
I get it.
No frill.
And also just important because it's
rare that you see guys of this caliber
going
at it like this.
I mean,
it's super exciting.
Fight.
Great fight.
I'm worse than shy fighting.
Now he's starting to do mma isn't,
you know,
he was calling out conor mcgregor for a
second just to get a little like they're
talking about stuff and doing stuff,
but,
but will,
it actually helped me when they talked
about Macau do on mma for a long time
because he was trained in a little bit,
but.
But is he going to actually do it?
I don't.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Well,
what's interesting about Thai fighters
is that they're really good in the
clinch and taking people down,
you know,
and really good at avoiding being taken.
Yeah.
Well a lot of people don't understand
how much similarities there are when it
comes to the clench and wrestling and
judo and you know,
I went and trained with the black veil
judo team in San Jose before I had a
shoot boxing fight and they just could
not believe that I could hang with their
high level black belts.
And I'm like,
well,
it's all this kind of similar stuff.
Like yeah,
your setups might be a little bit
different,
but all the fundamentals that go into
more Thai clinch are very similar to a,
to judo.
It's just a difference of things you can
and cannot do.
But,
but the base in the fundamentals of it
go across the board.
Yeah.
You see that a lot with,
uh,
with sweeps and trips and like you see
some really interesting trips and sweeps
in Moitai that are really very,
very technical about manipulating guys.
Setting them up in one direction and
changing direction on them and throwing
them to the ground.
It's really cool stuff to see.
A lot of the stuff in the tight clench
is very similar to a greco wrestling,
you know,
a all upper body a throws and stuff
because we can't shoot in,
but everything we can do is above the
waist and in those kind of manipulations
and off balancing.
And that's why like,
like if I just do Greco wrestling,
I,
I do pretty well,
you know,
and people are often surprised by how
well my wrestling or Jujitsu is if I'm
just messing around and doing it because
there's so many similarities.
Right.
You know what I mean?
That makes sense.
Now when you're watching fights in
Thailand,
they judge the clench is a very
important part of the fight.
Whereas a lot of times,
and in America when you're looking at
the clench,
we think of it the same way.
We look at a clench in boxing.
You guys are just stalling.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a way to dominate and,
and show your strength and ability over
over your opponent.
You know,
and if you can control someone and
damage them and then in laying these
clean knees on someone,
it's showing your superiority over them,
you know?
But again,
like you said here,
we don't have a good understanding of
it.
So yeah,
we just viewed as,
oh,
they're just,
they're just resting or they're just,
they're not doing anything in there.
You know what I'm saying?
No.
When guys take guys down and Moy,
Tai,
like how much does that count?
Like how are they scoring fights
obviously knockdowns or critical,
but if you dump a guy a bunch of times,
meaning you sweep them and trip,
I'm going to slam on his back.
How much of a factor is that an in a
fight?
It should be a huge factor if they're
scoring these correctly because again,
showing your,
your balance,
your dominancy are in your control is,
is one of the most important thing.
So,
so being able to throw someone in the
ground and,
and,
and you're,
you're still just standing there is,
is huge.
A huge scoring thing is how you're doing
it important because like what if you
just get double under hooks and just
crush them towards you and just send
them over and um,
you know,
it's,
there's so many factors that go into it.
And again,
if you have a,
a judge or a ref that basically has a
very elementary understanding of this
sport,
they can't give you an accurate,
a judge of this or,
or an accurate reading of this because
they,
they're not.
So their knowledge isn't so deep.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like,
it's like,
like me watching a,
a Jujitsu match and trying to score it.
Like I can kind kindness,
score it,
but I wouldn't be able to if I spent my
life in the sport,
you know what I'm saying,
what I'm kind of getting out.
It was style points by five points,
you know what I'm saying?
And cool something dope,
you know,
beautiful.
Sweep them on his bad side,
somebody and seamlessly do it and make
it look like nothing as opposed to I'm
like falling on top of them and we both
lose their balance.
Of course,
yeah,
yeah.
Without a doubt.
That's a weird thing to like objectively
call though,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Judging is such a strange thing.
It's tough man.
And I'll be the first one to admit that.
It's a very complicated thing.
You know,
I've just fighting my,
I don't know,
like,
yeah,
you know it and then I'm thinking,
trying to think of it from the mentality
of someone that's never done this before
or only taken like a course.
I'm like,
how can,
how can you do that?
I have a hard time doing it and I've.
I've spent 15 years doing this sport and
you had a controversial loss in lion
fight.
I fought,
I fought crump.
Ed Tie with over a couple of hundred
fights.
And that was your first loss.
That was my first loss that I didn't
think you lost that fight.
They overturn it.
They did?
Yeah.
For Ya.
18 never happened.
So 18 judges from all around the world
or something like that.
I can do that.
I,
I guess I honestly,
I didn't care.
I still don't because I had a great
fight and I put everything on the line.
I,
I did.
I thought I did the best that I could.
You know,
there's,
I mean there's some things that I think
I could've done better.
Like it was a great fight,
no doubt about it.
It was a close fight,
But I thought you won.
And I watched and I was like,
hmm.
And then,
uh,
I remember Pat Miletich and Michael
Chevelle,
we're both saying they thought it was a
bad decision.
Yeah.
And so then I'll watch it again and I
said,
well,
I'm going to watch it one more time.
And I was like,
man,
I think that was a bad decision.
And I remember now that you're saying
that,
I remember hearing that it was
overturned.
I think maybe they brought it up on a
broadcast afterwards,
during your next wide.
Is that what happened?
Is that when they brought it up again,
maybe I'm making this up.
It was the next event.
It wasn't fighting on it,
but they broke up and I was on the
broadcast.
Is that rare that they overturn a fight?
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
I'm pretty sure it's rare.
Yeah.
I never,
I never seen it.
I mean it's such a tough thing,
especially especially in a fight that
wasn't like so lopsided,
you know,
relatively close.
It's just a matter of how,
how you're viewing it,
what you're,
what you're giving more or less credit
too.
And it seems like a simple thing to do
on the outside.
Well
he hit him more or while he rocked him
more,
but,
but there's so many levels to.
This is Kinda like we were talking about
earlier,
it's not,
it's not an on or off thing,
it's a dial,
you know what I mean?
In and unless you're in there,
you can't even tell how much impact this
is doing it,
how much it's really hurting you,
you know,
from the outset.
And that's why it's very important.
It is especially like for the ties to
have that stone cold face where
nothing's affecting them because you
don't really know this person.
Could you just get crushed with a,
with a right hand and they didn't even
move or,
or show anything.
It makes it very difficult for for a
judge to say,
well,
this punch should get this,
this amount of credit or this much
credit as opposed to just that pit or
pet stuff so you know it.
It's very difficult thing to do and to
do correctly and accurately because
there's so many variables and so many
things you're seeing or not seeing.
Depending on where you're sitting,
how you're viewing it.
If you're in there,
if you're out there,
if you're on the left side of learning
the right side of the ring,
there's there's.
It's too complex a thing to.
That's why I could never say anything
about a decision.
It's like,
well,
it's such a difficult thing to do.
Unless it was so one sided.
You're like,
how in any way could you view this?
But if,
if any fight is relatively close,
I don't see how you can complain really
about the decision because no matter
what,
sometimes you're going to be on one side
of it and sometimes you're going to be
on the other side of it where maybe you
didn't win and they gave it to you.
You know?
One of the things I love about talking
to fighters and especially about putting
on a podcast is I think it gives people
the impression of fighters that like a
similar impression to what I have.
I think a lot of people have the wrong
impression.
They have this impression that fighters
are all,
hey,
I'm a bad motherfucker.
I'm out there to fuck the world and kick
ass and.
But really the very best fighters are
almost all very intelligent and very
complex people.
And what,
what you do when you fight,
when you compete is a,
is like a representative of your focus.
It's like all the stuff that you had to
do to get to that moment,
especially after you've done it a few
times and you're aware of all the
demands and you've really risen to the
occasion on more than one time and you
realize like all the variables that are
involved in it,
you know,
it's cool talking to you guys and,
and,
and going over that stuff.
And it's sort of.
I think there's a lot of people that are
listening right now and like,
these fucking guys are sharp like this.
There's a lot going on to this that I
didn't think.
It's a thing that you don't.
You don't see the whole thing.
Yeah,
ever,
ever.
It's like when it comes to fighting,
you're viewing 15 minutes of something
someone put their entire life into.
You judge them on this very small
fraction of a moment in their life in
that.
That's why fighting is one of the,
I think more stressful sporting things
you can do because we put so much into
such a little thing that is viewed in
this is the only thing we're judged on
were not judged by how hard we train or
how much do we kill ourselves or the
things we've had overcome and the gym.
It's like
what you did on that day in that moment
and how how you came across it means
everything.
You know what I mean?
Whereas other things,
there's other other ways around it and
you're like,
yeah,
you could have a bad day,
but tomorrow you're going to have a
better day.
It's like,
this is the day.
This is the only day and not the only
day.
Fifteen minutes or half an hour,
whatever it might be,
football that where there is a season
and okay,
we'll make it up the next game.
You know,
people don't really truly understand how
much goes into this and how much we put
and that's all I can say.
Every bad judges and bad reps.
it's like it's life and death.
Like you are literally have my life in
your hands and you are incompetent.
I mean even the UFC you lose three
times.
You get cut,
so sometimes twice.
Yeah,
exactly.
So yeah,
I mean depending upon,
there's a lot of variables that are
involved in that,
but what fighting is to me the way I
always like to describe it as high level
problem solving with dire physical
consequences.
And so when you watch someone who's
absolutely sensational at it,
you know,
like when you watch an Anderson Silva in
his prime,
you see some guy who's just figured out
a way through this puzzle and it's
really extraordinary way.
And there's,
there's a beauty to that that I,
I,
I think the people that really love and
appreciate fighting can,
can understand it and can feel it and
see it and I always want to try to find
a way to express that to other people.
Like,
do you see what I'm seeing?
No,
because if you saw what I'm seeing,
you'd be fucking freaking out just like
I am.
Yeah,
it's tough man.
Uh,
especially like he said,
if you don't have experience in that
sport or I've trained or fought in
yourself like you,
you can't appreciate it as much as
someone who hasn't.
It's just viewing it from the outside,
you know,
like,
what goes into this,
you know,
how hard it is,
what it feels like to get hit and you
know,
what it feels like to,
to have to come these obstacles and
training and preparing yourself for a
fight.
It's not just this surface thing like
two guys in the ring in there fighting
and silver and it's done.
When you saw there was some recent event
that uh,
what,
what was it,
NBC or whoever was putting it into,
they spent hundreds of millions of
dollars on boxing.
They had a few events,
they'd lost a shitload of money and then
it's done.
It's out and it falls apart.
I've watched something like that.
I'm like,
God damn,
they put so much effort into this.
If they just put together a fucking
stacked Moitai card just to stacked one
and just let people know.
I put it on prime time tv just like they
do with Fox,
with the UFC.
I feel like you can't miss.
I really do.
I just,
I feel like it's one of those things
where the product is there,
the talent is there,
the,
the fighters were established.
There's so much high level talent.
I mean when anybody watches Moitai even
in on tv live,
especially if they're like,
they just fall in love with it as,
oh my God.
Like we're where has,
where's the spin?
Yeah.
Where's this bed's here.
If you're a fan of exciting shit,
you should be a fan of time.
Definitely.
It's,
it's.
As we said earlier,
there's so many variables that go into
it and it's just a matter of the Dole,
those right pieces coming together at
the right time.
It's just like when the UFC really
started blowing up with Stephan Bonner
and forrest griffin fight,
like how long had it been around,
how many amazing fights had been going
on and it was just that the right time,
the right people,
the right thing blew it up.
Yeah,
it was 12 years old.
A lot of people forget he was 12 years
old when that happened.
How long did they struggle?
How much money they lose,
like how many promotions came and went.
And it's the same thing with Moitai.
It's just you don't know what the right
combination and the right time is and
hopefully one day those all those pieces
will come together.
Uh,
if,
if not,
we're just doing the best we can with
what we have.
Now,
you as a fighter and you're 34 now,
36,
36.
This is,
you know,
when you're an athlete,
this is the,
you know,
there's a,
there's a window Sanchez 36 to where
there's a window,
there's like what your body is going to
function at the level that it's at right
now for a certain amount of time and not
much more.
Yeah.
Does that,
does that fuck with you,
does that,
um,
when you think about them,
you know?
Um,
after,
uh,
after I had two really bad losses,
I lost my,
lost my world title,
um,
by stoppage and then I got knocked out
the next fight I was really struggling
mentally with,
with a lot of things like,
I don't know,
can I still do this?
You know,
I'm too old to do this.
And,
and I had all these questions in my head
and what I realized,
what Karen helped me realize right
before I won that a wmc title in Peru
was,
I've had all these questions from day
one.
I'm too old to do this.
I don't know if I'm good enough,
you know,
but my answer has always been the same.
Do I love to do this?
Yes.
Can I physically still do this?
Well then I'm going to do the best that
I can and give this everything that I
have and that's not going to change.
I don't know if that's going to be over
today,
tomorrow,
10 years from now.
You know what I mean?
So as long as I'm physically able to do
this and as long as I still have a love
and a passion for this,
I'm going to keep doing it.
I've been.
People have been asking me how long I'm
going to keep doing this for over 10
years.
The old expression that a fighter lives
and dies in their own mind,
you know,
and when you're at your best,
like you were telling me when you were
16,
you felt invincible.
You know,
when you're,
you're confident,
you can pull the trigger faster,
you have more belief in yourself.
When you're saying I'm just gonna do my
best.
Like when you,
when is there a thing in your head that
says,
man,
I wish I was in that state where I felt
invincible or does that not matter?
Yes and no.
It definitely does.
Um,
there there's a point where thinking
you're invincible,
it can backfire.
Sure.
You know,
like,
think about like Tyson course,
he was invincible,
but as soon as he lost that he,
it was,
he couldn't overcome it.
Have you ever heard Tyson talk about
what was going through his mind when he
was walking to the ring?
Have you ever heard them do that thing?
Have you heard him do it?
I fucking love that.
I've,
I've played that like 30.
You got it to that shit up because
there's something about that where it's
so raw and it's honest.
It's after he had been retired and you
know,
and he had just kind of reflecting about
all the nerves that would go through his
mind and all the Geckos.
Most guys are pretty much intimidated.
They lost the fight before flooding got
hit.
Most Guy I knew I needed.
I'm just going to doug.
I mean these guys know how to beat these
guys psychologically.
He finally got in the ring with them.
As soon as I come into come into the
ring,
I'm globe.
No stop.
That's not true.
While I'm in the dressing room five
minutes before I come out,
my gloves are laced up,
breaking my gloves down,
and I'm pushing the lever on the back of
my break in the middle of the glove for
my knuckle,
compares to the lack of feel,
Pearson against the tight leather gloves
on the everlast boxing gloves.
I come around,
I have supreme confidence and I'm scared
to death.
I'm totally afraid.
I'm afraid of Evec name,
afraid of losing.
I'm afraid of being humiliated,
but I'm totally confident.
Close.
I get to ring.
The more confidence I get closer,
more confidence.
I get closer,
I get all during my training.
I've been afraid of this man.
I thought this man may be capable of
beating me.
I've dreamed up from beaten me but that
well,
but I always stayed afraid of him,
but it was close.
I get to her and I'm more confident.
Once I'm in the ring,
I'm a God.
No one can beat me.
Oh my God.
I fucking love that.
I love that because that what you were
saying about all that work for that one
moment,
there's so much mind fucking going on.
Yeah.
So mental,
you know the thing like people don't
understand how mental fighting is and
they can't really appreciate it.
So the hardest part is after you have
been broken to still get that back and
that's a very tough thing to do.
So if you've gone undefeated for so
long,
you finally lose a lot.
A lot of people come back from that or
not.
A lot of people get back to the level
they were like,
I was very fortunate I've lost,
but I got crushed my first fight and I
was able to overcome that and to build
myself up and it helped motivate me.
And then I went onto win like 18 fights
in a row after that.
But I saw a lot of people go undefeated
for 10,
15 fights and they just had this amazing
confidence in.
You're just crushing everybody.
But they were also not learning a lot of
very important lessons that they needed
to learn.
And so once they finally lost it almost
destroyed them and it's very tough to
get so far in a game in,
in miss all these lessons you need to
learn until you're forced to learn them,
you know what I mean?
So if you can find a way to learn them
as well,
but nothing teaches as good as losing.
There's also losing,
I mean you see it in mma,
like fighters from different
disciplines,
maybe grapplers or something like that
that loose by Kao for the first time.
It's a different animal.
And that's what happened with me when I
was saying well my two losses,
like I'd never been.
I'd never been stopped while I've been
stopped but not,
I'm not really hurt or really knocked
out before.
And that happened twice in a row and it
was,
it was really devastating for me
mentally to have that happen and to try
to get back to where I was prior to that
and not just skill,
skill,
but that there's so many other factors
that go into this.
You know,
the way,
the way that you think about things.
It's like being confident but not over
confident,
being confident,
but in,
in,
in understanding the danger in that and
the things that'll keep you sharp with
that,
without affecting you.
It's like,
it's like finding that balance between
being too nervous and too calm.
Like I've always been more way,
way to calm,
like for my own good.
And I always kind of a calm dude most of
the time you're very mellow,
you know,
in,
in the beginning I thought everybody was
like that and then I would see people
getting ready for fights in there
freaking out and like they can't walk
into like I can't do this,
I can't do this,
I can't do this.
And these like high level people who
have been watching.
I'm like,
Jeez man.
what's wrong with you?
Like I don't understand,
like what are you so nervous about your
amazing,
you know what I mean?
But,
but I,
I one day I realized like being to calm
isn't so great either because I went
into a fight once and like I had no
adrenaline going.
I'm like half asleep like alright man.
And you know about the fight and this
guy is coming across the room from him.
I'm like,
alright,
this guy's going to try to kill you.
You'd better get going.
And it took me a whole round to get back
into that mental zone.
You've seen that cowboys for one video
of his breakdown walking a walk into the
cage?
No,
it's similar.
It's just like that where it's about his
mental approach process and everything.
It's really good.
He's changed a lot of stuff in his game
and he's a God that has survived some
pretty devastating losses and come back
even better.
And that's,
that's.
That is really the key because no matter
eventually if you do this long enough,
those things are gonna happen.
And how if and how you overcome them is
really what shows you what it would a
great fighter is because anybody that
goes around winning and just crushing
people's as great and all.
But if you haven't ever come back from
total destruction,
you're not a complete fighter.
I don't feel.
Yeah.
Cowboy since the dos Anjos fight is the
best version of cowboy ever.
And before that it was the pettis fight,
the pettis fight,
he got stopped and Pettis fight came
back.
And better than that,
he's a guy that is like the adversity
builds him.
It makes him stronger.
Have you ever worked with a
psychological coach or a.
yeah,
a little bit,
uh,
back when I was in Vegas,
um,
you know,
I,
I originally started doing it because I
broke my hand three times in a year and
I was always so hesitant to throw it and
I'm like,
I don't.
It's always painful and stuff.
I know it was just like mentally
couldn't get over it.
And I started a,
um,
that was how it originally started
working with a mental coach with like a
sort of hypnosis but,
but more just the getting,
uh,
getting to that right mind frame,
like going into the ring.
And then I started going from there as
like very specific things wanted to work
on
because it's all about having that right
mentality when you get in there or when
you're getting into training as opposed
to just going through the motions and
you can get very.
Especially when he'd been doing this for
so long,
you can get very comfortable in too
comfortable and that's one of the
problems I've had,
especially being so calm as I am,
it's very easy for me to just be like
whatever,
you know,
like we're just seeking out.
So you're,
I'm sorry I could do it.
So like it's your mental coach would
help you with your mindset for training
to prepare,
training,
training as well as fighting,
um,
you know,
what kind of stuff did you work on?
Like,
well,
like for training,
just having that,
that,
that I'm like,
I'm here for a purpose.
I'm here to,
to very specifically build myself up,
get ready for this fight.
I'm not just here,
I'm not here to work out.
It's the difference between working out
and training and that's something like
you're very focused on the task at hand
and what,
why are you doing this?
You're doing this to be the best in
that.
And they're like,
you're getting ready for this date.
You need to give it all you have at this
very specific moment.
And instead of just casually getting
through the training,
you know,
you're doing everything you're supposed
to do,
but if you're not mentally doing that as
well,
when you get into the ring,
you're going to fight in that kind of
laid back casual way as opposed to this
being this very,
um,
you know,
dangerous thing you're doing.
So you're training your,
your specifically gearing up to an
event.
Yeah.
Just dialing everything in,
you know what I mean?
And,
and,
you know,
some people have more of that automatic
thing and they're like,
when I'm in the gym,
I'm very focused,
very determined.
I'm doing this for this specific goal.
Um,
but,
but after you've been doing this for so
long,
it just becomes like that.
I'll just get through it and do it.
And if you kind of almost get lazy,
mentally not,
I've never been lazy physically.
Um,
you know,
I've always pushed myself almost too
much.
But uh,
mentally,
uh,
there's been times when I've had those,
those bad fights is one I've allowed
myself to slip.
Whether that's because,
you know,
I just,
the person I was fighting didn't,
didn't give me enough a threat in my
mind or,
or are there was some things going on
outside the gym,
will have family and you know,
pets dying and things like that,
that,
that kind of baroque certain things to
me down where I was still doing the
work,
but mentally I was just broken.
Relationships are a big one with
fighters,
right?
Yeah.
You know,
when you see fighters,
they get broken up relationship or they
have a crazy girlfriend or something.
Like there's a lot of fighters,
like there's a body mind used to work
with fighters and it would seem like
every time his fighter was getting to
get ready to compete,
his girlfriend would have some fucking
major drama and waking him up in the
middle of the night screaming at him and
she just wanted to fight.
Like as he was gearing up to a fight
because he was pulling away from her and
concentrating more on what this event
was going to be.
So she didn't like the fact that he was
spending less time paying attention to
her.
So she started getting super needy and
it would fuck them up every time.
It's tough man and that's why you'll see
a lot of fighters leave and go away to
camps,
you know,
things like boxers and stuff.
They'll totally
leave town and set up shop somewhere
else because you have to be so focused
on this one thing.
I mean your life is on the line,
even just in the gym or the life is on
the line.
We don't really don't really think about
it or,
or,
you know,
put that much emphasis on it.
But every day we get in there we,
we risk a injury and death,
which is obviously a severe case,
but.
But it happens definitely in.
If you're not taking the necessary
precautions and going into it with,
with that right mentality,
then you can get hurt really bad.
What were you going to survive?
I'm really lucky.
You know,
I,
I've been with Karen since I was 16,
so he's not only been my coach but he's
also been my mic,
my mind coach.
He knows me so well,
you know,
he knows as soon as we're going to hit
pads,
if something's going on,
you know,
or I'm in my head or anything he knows
by just my,
my body movement.
Uh,
he's like,
Hey,
what's up?
What's going on?
Let's get,
let's get out of your head.
Come on.
Are we going to,
we're going to work with what's the
deal?
You know,
he,
he knows me so well that he knows he,
he can see it a mile away even just by
my texting or whatever.
And you know,
I'm really lucky and that's why it's so
important to have.
And it's not just a great coach or a
great team,
it's having people around you who know
you and they can see these elements that
maybe someone who you haven't been
around long enough wouldn't see before.
They might not pick up on just that very
subtle vibe you have.
I'm like,
dude,
like what the hell is going on with you?
Even though you're doing everything
correctly,
you're training really hard.
But like you can see that that thing
that's off in their head and like,
that's what,
what's great though,
to have people who you're friends with
and had been around for a long time.
It was like,
I can see that in him.
He can see that in me and be like,
dude,
like,
you know,
like we're going to talk about something
like,
what's going on with you.
Like maybe you could just ease back a
little bit and you need to fix that
thing,
whatever.
And there's so many things that could
be,
you know what I mean,
whether it's you overthinking the fight
or whether there's something going on
with someone outside the gym or you're
just,
you've just got a bad vibe or it's in.
It's knowing when sometimes you got to
take a little step back and maybe not
push yourself so hard,
but be like,
hey man,
just ease back a little bit.
You know?
It's all about finding that winning
combination,
whether it's,
you know,
and obviously your mindset,
what you need to think about.
It's probably going to be different than
gas.
Tom.
Totally different.
Probably going to be different than,
you know,
fill in the blank joe shillings mindset.
Everybody's got their own little weird
tweaky shit that you have.
So I can't just tell him,
oh,
just do this.
Right?
So like people will ask me,
well,
what should I do mentally to prepare
myself?
I'm like,
I have no idea.
I don't even know for myself what that
is because it's a constant learning and
adjusting things can change every camp.
You know,
people don't like that.
People like to be able to show up at
work at 9:00.
There's a coffee break at 10:30,
you know,
at noon they'd go to lunch at 5:00 PM,
they go home,
you know,
it was that easy.
Don't you hate it?
You hate it.
I would hate it.
I would have.
I'm like,
why?
This is stupid.
Everybody can do this.
Well,
when you've experienced life at 10,
like you guys are living,
you know you're living this extremely
dangerous,
difficult,
incredibly complex
life.
I mean,
the task of being a professional combat
sports athlete is one of the most
difficult jobs that is available to a
person really is.
It's incredibly difficult.
Psychologically.
It's not just difficult.
It's difficult across the board.
There's not a single fucking thing
that's easy about it and to find the
right formula to make that thing work
for you.
It's.
It's so it's,
it's.
There's so much involved.
Yeah,
and you really have to pay attention to
it because the longer you let things
slide and don't realize like,
hey,
you're letting this slip over here,
the harder it is to make those
adjustments.
That's why I was saying like every day
it's you're on both sides of of too much
or too little of of one thing or
another.
Whether it's training,
whether it's your mental approach,
whether it's your diet,
whether it's how much or how little
you're running there.
There's so many variables that go into
everything.
What about strength and conditioning?
You guys do follow a strength
conditioning routines,
tons
tons up.
What kind of stuff do you do?
I can't even begin to describe this
stuff.
You know,
a lot of sprints.
It just really depends on.
It switches every day and again,
it's that thing where you have to find
what works best for you on that day,
in that moment,
in that,
in that certain fight,
it's like how,
how much is too much or how little is
too little and your dial in.
I didn't constantly and some because
sometimes you go to a bail,
okay,
this is what I'm going to do tomorrow,
but then you wake up and you're like,
this is not going to work for me today,
man.
Four or sometimes just doing it for the
sake of like,
yeah,
I'm going to do it because I don't feel
like I'm doing what I need to push
myself.
Sometimes that's not the wisest thing.
Just pushing yourself for the sake of
pushing yourself isn't always the right
answer.
You know what I mean?
And and trying to find that is very
difficult.
It's like I was saying before about like
what injury is too bad to where you
should take this fight off and once an
hour.
What's that?
What's that Ninja?
Oh,
I stubbed my toe,
like going into my world title fight.
I busted my rib like a nine days prior
to.
I couldn't even breathe.
I couldn't even move for two days.
Like,
Hey,
maybe you should not fight in.
Yeah,
that went through my head of course,
because I couldn't do anything.
I couldn't even touch it,
but I'm,
I'm always somebody,
like I said I'm going to do it no matter
how that was broken.
Was it a intercostal tear?
The tear of the tissue in between the
ribs?
Yeah,
that's very painful.
So it was,
when it happened,
my rib was sticking out like that,
pop it back into place and like duct
tape it down and I literally couldn't
take a breath and I was like,
how am I going to fuck?
I can't even train.
I still got like over a week to go,
you know,
I gotta make weight,
I got to do all these things and it's
all.
I'm laying in bed for two days just
taking these short breasts.
I couldn't lay down,
I couldn't sit up and I'm just like,
I've been working so long to get to this
point and this happens to me right
before,
like,
it was brutal.
So what'd you end up doing?
I have fought and crushed him.
Find out.
Did you,
uh,
did you get a cortisone shot or anything
in it?
And uh,
no,
I got,
I got a lot of body work done.
Um,
I worked with my,
a mind coach a lot like,
cause I was just like,
literally if somebody touches me there,
I'm,
I'm done.
Like I'm,
my body's going to fall.
Like even if I'm mentally strong,
that's what I was so worried about.
I was like,
I'm gonna go out there and guys just
touched me.
I'm gonna fall in like,
oh,
knock me out.
You know what I mean?
I was really worried about that,
but I was like,
well,
you know what?
He still has to do it.
He might go the whole fight not even
touched me.
You know what I mean?
I can't be so concerned about this one
thing that I'm not going to allow this
to break me.
You know?
It's like,
at what point do you do allow things to
break you?
And I'm like,
there's nothing that's going to break
me.
There's nothing going to stop me if I
can physically get in there,
I'm going to do it.
There's a fine line that people make
when they're training and they're
putting together a schedule.
There's a big debate,
especially in mma over how much strength
and conditioning you should do versus
how much fight specific skill training
you should do.
Where do you guys fit in on that and how
do you make the distinction?
I feel like there should be a balance
between both.
You know,
you gotTa,
you gotTa know what you're.
So you think you have to do strength
conditioning.
Definitely.
Definitely,
definitely.
Absolutely.
And then you should run.
There's a lot of fighters,
other MMA fighters that don't run around
running,
sprinting,
strengthening,
conditioning.
But again,
it's different for every person.
Now when you say running,
do you run distances?
Do you run hills miles at a time?
We do a lot.
We have the shortest run that I do is
four miles a night.
Most of the Times I do that twice a day.
So you're running eight miles in a day.
I mean,
it just really depends.
You know,
how I'm feeling that day that,
so I go either for,
you know,
whatever.
But I,
I,
everyday I have to get my running.
Otherwise I feel like I'm not training.
Really.
Yeah.
So you do the run in the morning and
then you train at night,
is that.
So I run,
I usually,
so Monday,
Monday is kinda like a,
it's not as long as,
as long of a day for me.
Like I have like a long training session
in the afternoon,
but then Tuesday I run,
then we do strength and conditioning.
Then they come back in the afternoon
when they hit pat's a,
then we all parked together,
you know,
so that's Kinda like a longer day for
me.
So you have a couple days where it's
just a big brutal,
crazy day.
So that's like four workouts you're
doing,
you're running,
running,
conditioning,
running again,
pat work,
sparring,
you know,
then pull up neck exercises to crossfit
in there.
And I really try.
I try to put everything that I can into
my training.
So fight day comes.
I'm like,
there's nothing else I could have done.
This is it.
But you also have to find that balance
between those things too.
So it's not like I can't 100 percent
crush every single thing I'm doing.
I can't sprint for miles,
crush the pads as hard as I can,
as hard as I can kill the bag as hard as
I can,
you know what I mean?
It's what is it that you're working on
in that moment,
you know?
And am I just working on my technique
and my things in my footwork and my
movement and as well as that.
So it's not like every time we do
strength and conditioning it's just full
on kill yourself.
Sprint,
you know,
or it might be.
And then,
but later on maybe we're doing a little
more technical stuff so we'd definitely
switch it up at the gym.
Yeah.
How do you man,
I mean that,
that balance,
which is what's interesting about it is
like how do you know the right way to go
about it?
Like don't fade or towards the end of
his career.
I mean he's obviously back now,
but towards the end of his mma career,
he abandoned all strength and
conditioning and he's just doing fight
training,
which is again,
it's what works for the individual,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like what would I do?
I was not going to tell everyone you
need to do this because then you're
going to be like me.
Like we don't have the same schedule.
We were very different in the thing we
do.
We do a lot of stuff together,
but there's a lot of stuff we don't do
the same at all.
What's the differences between you two
terms?
Training?
I probably don't.
I don't run as much as he does anymore.
I used to.
Yeah.
But like the older I get,
the less I'm running.
Like I paid it man.
Hey,
I'm like,
I've done,
I've done the running.
But is there a benefit to you?
Do I mean,
is there anything wrong with you not
doing it?
I don't feel so.
No,
but you have to find a way to make up
for that.
You know,
like I know people who hardly run at
all,
but they also find a way to stumble a
supplement that,
you know what I mean?
They might do a lot harder.
Bag backgrounds are a lot more rounds,
you know,
when it comes to that where you know
there's not just one thing you have to
do this,
this many rounds is this many miles.
You have to do,
you have to eat exactly like this.
You have to do it exactly like this.
It changes and it changes for me daily,
weekly,
a fight.
Every fight is different.
You know,
I might do more,
do less,
you know,
I've had fights where I couldn't run
because I snapped all the tendons in my
ankle and I had to swim instead,
you know,
and I still feel great now.
Fight.
And I have felt like I had just as much
cardio and I had to.
I had to make up for it somehow.
In other aspects of what I was doing.
You're making up for this.
Your,
the one who's got this schedule in your
head.
So there's that mind fuck of am I
slacking off or am I pushing myself hard
enough?
And how do you know that Kinda that
kinda comes from the way I came up.
You know,
I came up with high trainers who didn't
speak English,
you know,
I had to learn everything very much.
So by doing it myself and figuring it
out myself,
you know,
I never had had people telling me what
to do or what I should eat,
what I shouldn't eat,
everything I've done and learned.
Most of what I've done and learned has
been by application.
I find it hilarious and fun to watch
when you see Thai guys training with
American people and American people
don't speak Thai and the Thai guy
doesn't speak English and they're trying
to teach them a technique and you know,
they're just kinda like doing it with
your hip and you know,
it's this weird thing where you're
looking at each other and they're trying
to figure what the other guy's saying.
Well,
it's interesting because I didn't,
I didn't really start thinking of how
complex what I was doing was until I
started teaching people.
Because I'd been doing this for almost
10 years before I actually started
trying to train people and I remember
the first time I taught somebody,
or maybe it was a seminar,
something.
I'm like,
well,
just kick,
you know,
just just do it,
do it.
And then I'm like,
oh,
well you gotta do this,
you gotta do this.
And I'm like,
Geez,
there's like 15 steps involved in just
the kick.
Well that's funny you said that because
we worked out today and you're very
complex.
I mean you got.
I mean we were talking just about the
switch kick and I think you went on this
10 minute rant of just all the different
variables that are involved in it.
It was very illuminating.
It was awesome.
I did it again.
It was,
it was.
I learned it by doing it,
but it wasn't till teaching it that I
had to figure out what all those steps
were and which has helped me in what I
do and help me improve a lot of the
techniques I have and realizing all the,
the complexity of every technique of
every movement in it.
And when I explain it to people and then
I train people,
a lot of it is just me telling them how
you do it,
you know,
were were,
were how I learned was just just do it
like go run,
go kick the bag.
Like hey,
you gotta fix this.
And like by watching and studying.
And that's how it really how I learned
what's interesting.
And maybe unfortunately there's a,
you could train with a lot of people and
they would never point out some of the
stuff that you guys pointed out today.
It's finding someone who's technically
proficient and understands how to,
how to relay that information.
It's one of the harder parts of being a
martial artist unless you're a self
starter and you just do a lot of.
Well now today obviously when you're a
day you can do youtube,
but now you can just get online.
You can watch a million.
Yeah.
But you might find some shitty ones too.
I've found some shitty ones on all sorts
of things where they don't know what the
fuck they're talking about on all sorts
of different martial arts techniques.
Well,
it's the thing that Kinda like the
unfortunate part,
a lot of times high level people didn't
really have to learn things because it
came so naturally.
They didn't have to learn all the
fundamental aspects that go into this
technique,
whereas somebody that might not be as
good,
they've studied it a lot more and that's
why a lot of times you'll see not the
highest level of fighters be the better
coaches because they had to study it so
much more and they've had to really look
into it and dissect it that much more
because they weren't able to or or for
whatever reason do it so naturally.
Like Freddie Roach.
Yeah,
without a doubt.
He.
I mean he was amazing fighter,
but he's a good fighter,
really good fire fighter,
but he,
you know,
he wasn't,
he wasn't mayweather.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Where you know,
maybe others,
probably not the best coach in the
world,
I don't know,
but a guy like Freddy Roach has really
had to develop that and figure those
things out and he can tell somebody
else,
how do you do that?
This is how you do it because I've had
to figure it out,
you know what I mean?
And that's something like I've gone a
gone out of my way to do,
like it was much more natural for me to
do,
but,
but throughout the years I've,
I've realized that,
you know,
and how do I tell someone how to do
this?
I've had to figure out what those things
are and how do I,
how do I tell someone how to do this
work because I can just do it just by
doing.
I can watch somebody do something and
I'm like,
I'm going to do it,
but,
but how do I explain this to somebody
and I've had to dissect my,
my own self and realize all these things
and all these aspects of the technique
and it allows me to translate that to
somebody else as well as fine tune it in
myself.
Now,
when you guys watch mma and you see
someone like Stephen Thompson that has a
few elements of Moitai he uses,
but he uses a lot of sport karate,
which is a completely different stance
and completely different style.
What's your take on that when you wash
that will,
what his style or when they say,
well,
they definitely don't really mean well
with leg kicks in some techniques,
but essentially he's doing a sport
karate style.
Well,
it was kind of the same thing with
Anderson Silva.
It's like just because someone's
throwing an elbow,
just because somebody has a clenched
doesn't necessarily make it more tie.
There's a lot of arts that have those
things.
You know what I mean,
and I'm not going to view him as a
Moitai Meta.
I think of Anderson is a more Thai
fighter.
Not at all.
He thought of himself as a Moy Thai
fighter.
That's okay,
but.
But I wouldn't view them as a fighter at
all.
I know is an MMA fighting.
Anything he did was very moist.
Even his clench was.
I mean that's such a fundamental basic
clench,
you know what I mean?
And that's just because everyone else
was so terrible at it.
It's like grab the neck,
like you don't see that in high level
Muay Thai guys going up and grabbing
each other by the neck.
It's in transition and one of the hurt
people when they get tired very,
it's very much a,
um,
us of struggling for dominance over
under those kinds of things,
but a big sloppy,
ridiculous arm bar.
Yeah,
Dude.
It's like,
that's like day one more time.
So when you saw the,
like the rich Franklin fight with the
fuck,
like how did he not learn this this
first day in training and what was even
worse was I had a friend that I trained
with that went out to help him for the
second one and he just didn't want to
hear it.
Like they did not want to hear that.
Like,
dude,
you don't know what you're doing at all
because as we talked about earlier,
these guys get to a high level and think
that their,
your technique is good.
And I'm like,
dude,
you are like a kindergarten,
like you don't know what you're doing at
all whatsoever.
He didn't want to listen.
So.
Wow,
that's crazy.
So who was it that went out with him?
Uh,
Anthony Brown.
Oh,
hold a training partner of mine.
And he was specifically brought there
because of his more time.
Yeah,
without a doubt.
I'm like,
why would you,
why would you bring me in if you're not
going to use me?
I mean,
I've been brought in for people to and
like,
why wouldn't you use what you've brought
me in here to do?
You know what I mean?
Like you brought me in for my,
for my knowledge and the singing.
You just want to keep doing what you're
good at.
Like,
why am I here?
This is stupid.
That's unfortunate.
He's such a nice guy and such a smart
guy.
He was a math teacher without a doubt.
How do you not see the math of that?
It's when people aren't.
People have a false sense of where
they're at in the sport and what they
can do and like you literally know
nothing,
but you have this mentality that you're,
you're decent at standup,
you're decent at.
When we tie in your terrible compared to
someone that really does know what
they're doing.
You know what I mean?
Most people's understanding is very
elementary.
If that,
you know,
you take another person in.
I'm on,
I can beat you without even touching
you.
You know what I mean,
and just let you mess yourself up
because you don't really know what
you're doing.
That's a.
it's crazy to think that someone could
reach the world championship level in
something that involves more Thai,
but there's so many variables that come
into.
There's wrestling,
there's Jujitsu,
there's always things.
There's you can get away with a lot
more.
Like the striking in mma you can get
away with because of those variables,
because of the smaller gloves,
because of the takedowns,
you know,
you put that person in the ring with
even a moderately good.
When we tie person a moderately good
boxer,
if they're going to get murdered,
you know what I mean?
Right.
Just like it can bring like a really
good fit for him,
but they don't have any wrestling
defense defense or no Jujitsu.
I'm not going to do it.
Be able to do.
Exactly.
Look like an idiot.
It's.
Well,
that's one of the appeals of MMA.
Yeah.
Is that the guy who wins is most likely
the best fighter because if it was just
more tie or if it was just wrestling or
if it was just Jujitsu,
you would see someone who's the best at
that,
but when you throw everything in,
like it's the kitchen sink get in there
and that's when you know,
you get to see like who's been.
I mean,
it's even more complex puzzle.
That's why I've never really understood
the argument of like pitting this person
against that person or who's got the
best Moitai never made well nobody
because they're not doing more tie.
Right.
So,
so that,
that argument,
that conversation is completely invalid.
Like,
Oh,
if you put this boxer and against this
Moy Thai fighter,
who's going to win,
I don't know what rules are they
fighting under their fighting under more
type roles are going to get crushed.
You know what I mean?
Well,
it's interesting that a wonderboy
Thompson is going to fight tyron
Woodley,
who's the UFC welterweight champion and
who's just a super powerful wrestler,
but he's also training with Duke Roufus
who's obviously very talented,
knows a lot about.
Great coach,
when you see a guy like that,
the reason why I keep bringing up
wonderboy styles because it's so unique,
you know,
we brought up Raymond Daniels in glory
who's one of the only guys that has that
similar background and then Michael Page
of course in mma fights were belt or has
a very similar style to that sport
karate style.
What are the holes in that style?
Like what's.
What's the pros and cons that you see as
a fighter?
What we were speaking of earlier,
it's,
it's if you've never applied that in a
fight,
a real fight,
not,
not point sparring,
not that,
that kind of thing.
There's certain techniques and things
that are completely worthless and
unfortunately in a lot of those sports
you are not.
You don't get exposed by that until it's
way too late.
So you're trying these techniques that
you know,
a,
a decent person just going to walk right
through because they look good and
they're flashy and they're great on the
pads and and all that,
but,
but when you have to damage someone,
right?
Obviously Thomson knows how to do that
though,
obviously it's using those techniques
and applying them in a more fight,
a centric way and it's completely
different thing,
but when you see what I was trying to
get at,
is that such a weird style where you
stand sideways and he leaps in and out
and he moves back and forth from the
waist,
like a snake.
I mean he's got a lot of.
There's a lot of weirdness to the way he
moves and it's very difficult to find
anybody that has that level skill with a
sport karate kickboxing,
but also has a really good wrestling
base to.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and I think that's one of the biggest
things in and why he's able to apply
those things because because he can deal
with the wrestling and everything else
that goes in so,
so that's why you'll see him throw those
techniques because he's not as worried
about it as someone who might be just as
good as him with those things.
It has zero ground wrestling or they're
not gonna throw it because they're going
to get taken down.
Crushed.
Yeah.
It's like we were talking about your
experience in a taekwondo school that
you went there the first day you started
doing sparring,
you through a low kick and then like get
outta here.
Time to go do it.
Something to do effective.
Yeah.
So being able to apply things in a real
fight and being able to apply them in
the air.
It is very different.
Right.
Obviously we've seen Thompson can apply
them in a real fight.
What is he doing that you see that's
different?
Like obviously it's not a Moy Thai
fighter,
he's a kickboxer,
but like when you see that stance,
that weird stance,
that sideways stance,
when you think about that?
Well,
I don't think much about it because I
don't watch a lot of MMA,
you know?
I mean I do,
I don't,
I wouldn't say I follow it,
you know what I mean?
I watched it when it's on and,
but I'm not a,
you know,
like paying attention to the fighters or
tracking them throughout the years,
you know that much.
I'm just so curious because you're so
Moitai,
you know your style so tiny.
You're obviously an expert at it.
I'm always curious as to like how a
person like you observes an expert
striker in sort of another realm.
La,
I think he's an expert and he's becoming
an expert striker in mma.
So he's,
he's applying all the techniques that he
knows that he knows and ha have worked
for him in MMA.
So it's different than if he would get
in the ring and do Moitai yeah.
How many fighters like him have done
Moitai?
Obviously Raymond Daniels has done
kickboxing and some you know,
and it,
but it's another one of those things
where being able to apply the things
from your other sport into that.
So like we were talking about with a
Raymond Daniels and Nikki hold skin,
like he just walked him down and he's
like Bop,
Bop,
crushing the Valtellina to.
So at a certain level it kind you,
you lose
that.
Like where you're spinning,
flashy techniques are going to work
against,
you know,
those,
those mid level guys,
but you put them in there with the best
in the world,
in a lot of that stuff gets exposed in,
is not working out so well,
and you think that essentially
demonstrates the effectiveness of Moitai
at the highest levels you think is the
best.
Demonstrates the,
the holes and some of the stances in
techniques.
Um,
if I'm not flinching on the things you
do and don't really care so much about
you hopping around and spin around,
I'm just walking down and crushing you.
You know that that's where that kind of
gets exposed.
So it's like,
it's like putting a boxer into a fight
I'm going to do is kick your legs and
you can't punch me.
You know what I mean?
But you take a box there and teach them
how to defend those kicks and standing a
little bit more of a squared up way.
And where I can't use you use your
weakness against you as much.
You're going to have much better success
even if you never throw a kick.
Now you just can take those kicks better
and just kill me with your,
your high level hands.
Will you,
you said that you had taken some boxing
matches I had for boxing floats in and
you just did it to stay active?
Yeah,
I mean there were all on like a week's
notice.
I,
one of them was like,
the day I got there,
like,
well this was when I was saying I was
out on all those fights fall through and
uh,
I went to this fight was supposed to be
a fight and I told the promoter way
ahead of time,
like,
look,
I've had all these fights fall through.
I'm not coming out there unless you have
a fight for me.
I'm like,
not only do you need to have a fight for
me,
I need you to have a backup guy for me
as well.
He's like,
don't worry,
don't worry.
We got it.
We got am like,
I'll call them before I went out there
and be like,
so the guys still gonna find me,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
You got the backup guy too,
right?
Yeah.
All right,
get out there.
Well,
uh,
yeah,
they both backed out.
So,
um,
I don't know what we're going to do.
I'm like,
look,
man,
day of have much of an issue.
Oh yeah.
And I was like,
look,
if you don't get me a fighter you need
to drag your ass into the ring and we're
going to fight because I have killed
myself and you promised me we had a
fighting saying,
Oh man,
I'm going to get you someone get you
somebody.
I'm like,
alright.
So I weighed in,
left,
came back.
He's like,
well we got somebody but uh,
he's a boxer.
It's a do you want to do a boxing fight?
And I used to carry my boxing shoes with
me just in case and I'll bring my
mouthpiece in my cup to fights even if I
wasn't fighting just in case,
you know,
because,
because it's ridiculous.
That's just how we came up,
you know what I mean?
And he's like,
well you can box.
I was like,
alright,
alright let's do it.
And this guy is standing right there.
He was freaking out because one,
he was like 20 pounds bigger than me.
I've never boxed the day in my life
before and he's like,
what is wrong with this guy?
And I was like,
yeah,
let's go man.
He's like,
well,
he's 20 pounds everything.
I'm like,
I don't care.
let's go.
I got some shoes,
like,
well,
I got some gloves,
let's fight.
And I went out there and knocked him out
and uh,
you know,
that was,
that was my first time boxing everybody.
It was always like that.
I like a last minute thing where I'm
like,
I can punch man,
like I'm going to do whatever I can do.
Now you're preparing for mma?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
how much different is your training?
Are you still taking more Thai fights as
well?
Well,
right.
Right now we're in the transition.
I just signed with belts are in
them.
I don't know what's coming next.
If it's going to be kickboxer I may,
but I'm definitely preparing for both.
And they haven't told you.
I don't know yet because we don't know
what Carla,
me,
I'm going beyond,
but I mean my,
my mma training,
even when we hit the paths,
as I stand differently,
I'm diff.
I'm moved differently when they're
training for MMA.
You know,
I'm doing a lot of MMA rounds actually
with the,
with the guy.
So from a team pseudo.
Well,
the good thing about mma is it'll still
allow you to do spinning elbows.
Yeah.
The bad thing about kickboxing is you
can't do spinning elbows.
Yeah.
People don't know.
That's one of your signature techniques
properly.
Your signature technique.
Mimo.
I mean,
you had some spectacular knockouts in
lion fight was spinning elbows.
Thank you.
And Yeah.
How the fuck could they take that away?
Well,
that's ridiculous.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I'm,
I'm really looking forward to doing both
to be honest.
I'm looking forward to uh,
you know,
improving on my boxing and really having
to exercise that,
that style of fighting and I'm really
looking forward to doing them in May as
well,
you know.
And you were fighting 1:45 in lion
fight,
low 40 mma.
I don't,
I don't know yet.
I'll probably start at 1:45 then going
down to 35.
You think you could make 1:35 big guy?
I can.
I've made 1:39 last time.
How much do you weigh right now?
Probably like one 60,
1:58.
God,
everybody's just killing themselves.
That to me is one of the most
unfortunate aspects of fighting is the
drastic weight cuts and I just think
that juice is not worth the squeeze.
I just feel like fighting itself is so
God damn difficult.
Like why complicated even further by
dehydrating your brain 24 hours before
the fight.
Yeah.
And that's why I cut down so much and
I've been working with my job for my
last three camps and has been great.
What is dolce got you doing differently?
Just like the fact that he sent.
He sends me all my Diet's like,
you know,
before I,
we,
I have like an off season diet as well,
you know,
so I'm just ready getting ready all year
round.
So do you have like a pre prepped meals?
Are there in the little containers and
you open them up and out of the cave is
a meal prep company that we have out
there in Dublin and Kevin sponsored by
them too,
so it's really easy.
So I just,
I get my diet from dolce.
I give him my,
I give out of the cave,
my diet and I just get my meal prep
every week.
Oh,
that's nice.
Yeah,
that's jargon.
It definitely makes it a lot easier to
not have to worry about cooking and not
have to worry about any of that.
And just training,
you know,
eating and good desk.
That is gigantic.
Now.
What is a primarily what kind of foods
are you eating and do very that.
And do you have different results with
different diets?
I,
my last diet was pretty good.
I will have like oats in the morning.
I'm oats in the morning with a chia
seeds and hemp seeds and that kind of
stuff.
Then I'll have my first workout,
my second meal will be eggs and then at
night I will have like fish or chicken
or anything like that with asparagus or
Broccoli.
I found that to be really successful,
you know,
so um,
if you do vary it,
like what
do you various far as like the fat
content versus the carbohydrate content
versus the protein content?
I mean,
do you,
uh,
do you mess around with that at all?
I use,
I used to do mostly a Paleo Diet.
It was 90 percent Paleo except for a
little bit of milk in my coffee,
but now I actually,
I had all these grains like oats and
brown rice at night and I feel great.
I feel better with that.
What was,
what is the difference between adding
the grains,
the extra car?
I have way more energy and interesting.
I have a lot more energy and my weight
is even lower than it was when I was
just trying to do,
you know,
all fruits and meats.
Yeah.
There's a certain amount of
carbohydrates that a lot of people that
are involved in like very strenuous
shit,
like whether it's a triathletes or
somewhere along those lines,
there's a lot of people that try,
um,
maybe the goal with a ketogenic diet.
I tried that a little bit and I just had
no energy.
It did not work for me.
I've heard that like I was just like,
I felt like I was brain dead.
How long did you do it for?
It was like about a couple of weeks.
And see that's the problem.
You're supposed to wait.
You're supposed to not even do anything
strenuous for the first three or four
weeks to your body transitions.
So in my case I was,
you know,
I'm always trying to get ready for
fights.
I was just like,
dude,
I have no energy.
Like I don't know what they call the
Keto flu.
Yeah,
it's A.
I know some guys have made the
transition successfully and then they
um,
they compete and they do a lot of things
burning off fat.
But I'm always curious about extreme
people,
like people that are doing ultra
marathons,
people that are doing things that are
extreme energy requirements,
you know?
Yeah.
Well I was living with the Karen at the
time and he was like,
I felt like a little bit is I did,
what the fuck are you doing?
Shit for you.
You need carbs.
You need,
you need,
you need that stuff.
I was.
You're not going to have any juice,
man.
Well,
if you talk to mark Sisson,
who he calls his diet the primal
blueprint,
let the whole problem with the term
Paleo.
Is that the Paleolithic era?
They ate a lot of grains.
I mean that's just not historically
accurate.
It's not a good word for it,
but the people that are successful with
it,
apparently it required.
There's a.
there's a curve where you go through
that Keto flu stage for a few weeks and
then you get better than you,
but I've talked to people that never get
better.
I mean I know some friends,
Jujitsu friends that went through the
whole process and didn't train hard for
three or four weeks and got themselves
to a state of Ketosis but just did not
feel right.
Yeah,
I mean I know it works for like power
lifters and stuff like that and people
like that,
but me as a fighter personally
experienced it for a little bit.
I just would not do it again.
Your description shows me that you
didn't really get through it,
the that you can't do it for two weeks.
He told me like mark system when I did
it,
he told me,
don't do anything hard for three weeks
to do anything.
Even if you like on the treadmill for 45
minutes just at a slow pace.
That's probably too much.
I think that was my mistake and I
training just
as hard as I always do,
but trying to eat like that.
I was like,
yeah,
it takes your body,
takes your body awhile apparently to
make that adaptation,
but it is controversial.
I mean it works for me and it works for
some people,
but obviously my lifestyle doesn't have
the same energy requirements that your
lifestyle.
Does it mean training for
fights?
I mean like all the things you've got to
find what works best for you.
That's why I like,
you know,
I'll make the adjustments.
I feel like I need.
If I need some more cars,
some more grains on a certain day or
going into a certain workout,
I'm going to have them.
That's why I wouldn't say I have a
specific diet,
I,
because it varies,
you know,
there's how I'm feeling,
what's working,
what's not working,
you know,
which guys get blood work done.
Do you get your blood work checked out,
have a uh,
I got a buddy in vegas who does that and
a years back,
um,
you know,
I,
I had my blood looked at it,
it was messed up man.
I had a lot of plaque in my blood and
stuff and I was really surprised.
It looked like it was really unhealthy
and I never would have known that if I
never had gotten it done.
What were you eating at the time?
The same stuff I'm meeting.
I think it was more of a hereditary
thing then,
uh,
then as far as my diet,
um,
yeah,
and what got me on a lot of,
uh,
like the red algae and,
and,
and uh,
I don't remember everything but we've
got to completely clear.
It was just crazy to see it.
Like I could see the blood and like
showed me like,
you know,
how it gets moving around.
So be like,
yeah,
there's a big chunk of a crystals right
there.
It's like,
that's not good,
man,
if there's.
Because it's only worse.
He was really surprised by how bad it
was.
This guy a doctor or is he like a
healer?
No,
no,
he was.
He was a phd.
Is legit.
Yeah.
Yeah,
fucking people.
You'd be amazed like world class
athletes that go to quacks and you know,
they'll come back and tell you
something.
Well,
I'm balancing out my alkaline and my
energy and my truck was what?
Huh?
What's going on?
Like I was,
it was,
it was nice to visibly be able to see
it.
Like him take a blood,
put it on,
things like that.
So you can see it in newspapers.
Yeah.
Wow.
So you're like a projection up on the
wall.
And I got cleared it up within like a
month or two.
What about like vitamin supplementation
or things along those lines?
Well now I'm hooked up with on it and
all their amazing stuff.
So I've been hooked up taking all their
multivitamins and things like that,
which all the other stuff's really
amazing.
Yeah,
we try,
we try to get the best shit,
but then there's stuff is awesome.
I mean like I have days,
you know,
towards the end of the camp that I'm
like dude,
like I cannot like even with my dad and
everything,
like you're so sore you,
you busted your ass for so long,
you know,
you're like,
I just scan and I've taken that Alpha
brain stuff and like that stuff puts you
on for sure.
Like
it's a great thing to take before
workouts and a lot of people don't think
of it as that because it's,
you think of it as something for,
for mental energy or for your memory or
for.
Yeah,
like I take it during sparring and I
feel like I'm,
I'm on like 100 percent.
I feel like,
um,
mental fatigue is a huge factor in
physical fatigue,
which is one of the next questions I
wanted to talk to you guys about.
Sources of inspiration.
Do you,
do you
actively seek out inspiration?
You know,
personally when I was,
when was the one that got knocked out?
18 17 when I got knocked out,
you know,
I had a really bad time after that,
like I said I was invincible and then I
had a really bad way cut that happened
and then I'm carrying,
brought out Kevin to help me out.
So Kevin's been Maya's per my
inspiration for the last,
you know,
since he moved out and every everyday
just seeing this guy,
you know,
how hard he works and how everything he
puts on the line everyday.
Like that's been.
Mine's my inspiration since then,
you know,
I mean,
I,
I knew Kevin before that,
uh,
the first,
the first time I ever saw Kevin,
I thought I saw Kevin fight.
I thought he was going to lose weight
here.
He fought coke.
I was supposed to be in that car.
The fight fell through and then I
watched them and then I'm talking to
Karen on the side.
He's like,
he was betting against me,
man.
I was like,
dude,
why coke?
I was like,
dude,
what's his full name?
A channel.
What?
Yeah.
And he was,
that was when I was like,
Damn,
who is that?
Because I,
at first I was like,
do white boys.
Yeah,
but to get smashed
you don't know Kevin Ross,
dude,
I know
smash this guy.
And I was like,
I was like,
after,
if I was like,
dude,
that was my new favorite.
That's funny.
And then you get to train with them.
Yeah.
What I meant was do you seek
inspiration?
Like do you read books about inspiration
or do you,
do you read anything about mindset or
psychology or anything along those
lines?
Um,
I read,
I read a lot,
um,
I'd say more and more along lines of
biographies and stuff,
like a Red Meat Micky Ward's book,
which is amazing.
And uh,
um,
that unbroken book,
which is unbelievable.
What's unbroken.
It's,
they made an Angelina Jolie made that
movie about it,
but it's about a fricking guy's name.
So the runner guy?
Yeah,
he was a runner and then it was a World
War II.
It was a great movie.
I thought it was really good and like,
oh,
that was the Japanese people torture.
Nomany went bad dude.
But like,
read that book man,
like,
like the movies,
like such a small fraction of what this
dude went through and like seeing how
much stuff he overcome,
not once,
not twice,
like every time you think there's no way
this guy can overcome this dated again.
Did it again?
Did it again,
like on unbelievable stuff,
man.
It's one of my more favorite books.
Um,
but like,
people like that,
I would say I seek that out and like
look through,
look for stories of inspiration,
you know,
not just fighters but uh,
in any,
in any order aspect of life in general.
I'm seeing the things that people
overcome.
It was,
as I said earlier,
you,
if you go and look at anyone's story,
who's ever made it,
like you can take inspiration for them.
Like seeing the struggles they went
through a,
it's,
it's unbelievable.
And,
and you know,
when we don't know these things,
we think of ourselves as the only ones
that have to overcome stuff or are
dealing with things that might have
slowed down.
But you're like,
well,
that guy had way worse than I ever did.
You know what I mean?
And that's why I've always treated,
tried to be very vocal about the things
I've struggled with and overcome.
And like the first highlight video I
ever had done for me,
it was very important for me to show
myself getting knocked out and dropped
in all of these things.
I'm like,
everyone just shows these highlights of
their life and it gives you a very
skewed perception of what it is we have
to deal with and go through,
especially to reach a certain level.
Like it's,
it's terrible,
man,
that we go through a lot and people
don't know because you just see the end
result of all this hard work and you see
the glamour and the lights and the
highlights and stuff.
But,
but you don't know what people have felt
overhead come with and dealt with things
I would crush.
And most people,
I think what's really important about,
um,
inspirational videos and books and
biographies and things along those lines
is it gives you an insight into
someone's perspective that you,
you,
you can find parallels,
you find parallels to your own life and
it normalizes some things that might
just seem incredibly confusing because
maybe to you,
it's the first time you've had to
overcome something that's so difficult,
but then you find out that other people
have done it as well.
And it kind of,
yeah,
it,
you can,
you can take a lot of comfort in people
that have gone before you.
Yeah.
Like we've all had to overcome
something.
You know what I mean?
Like just sitting down and talking to
somebody like hearing their story,
you know,
it,
it's,
it can be very inspirational and really
help you overcome anything you might be
facing.
And again,
that's why I've always been tried to be
very vocal about my story and share some
of my fight experiences or training
experience or life experiences.
Because,
you know,
most people don't.
They don't ever hear that side of,
of,
of fame if you want to call it that.
Like they don't see that we don't.
It doesn't get put out there like,
like,
like the successes.
Do you know,
you see everyone's success.
We don't see their failures.
Well
that's one of the things that I think is
interesting about you.
You're obviously a very intelligent guy
and you're a guy who's gone through a
lot of things,
but you're also a guy who wants other
people to know that you've gone through
all these things.
You're a guy who wants you,
you,
you're assuming not just this role of a
fighter,
but you're also assuming role as a
mentor and have a,
an example to those who are coming up.
Well,
it's something that's been very
important to me because like as I was
coming up before youtube and everything,
like I didn't really have anyone to look
at me like,
well he did it.
I can do it too.
So it was very,
it still is very important to me.
One of the most important things to me
to show people that they can do it,
you know,
into,
to show people when I say how late I
started in,
in where I was and the things I've
overcome,
because when you've,
when you've seen that someone's done it
before you or similar and overcome these
things,
it makes it that much easier.
Um,
for the next person.
There's a really amazing book called the
rise of Superman and uh,
I don't know if you're read it,
they talk about,
um,
like,
like the,
the leaps we've made an athletic.
So,
um,
you know,
they're more talking about like extreme
sports.
And I'm,
one of the things they were talking
about was the,
uh,
you know,
the four minute mile and it's like,
that used to be physically thought of as
impossible.
Whereas now it becomes a requirement for
people to do.
And like kids in high school are doing
it where,
where were they used to think of it like
there's no way you can physically do
this.
Uh,
and they were there.
They brought up,
I think it was like the $900 on a
skateboard.
It was impossible to do,
it's like there's no way you can do this
and then a Tony Hawk or whoever did it
and now like eight year old kids can
pull this off because you,
that thing that's viewed as impossible
becomes the norm and as soon as that
happens,
you can get to the next level and the
next level,
and the only way to do that is for
someone to break through whatever that
impossible thing is and if,
and if these things aren't put out there
and people don't know about them,
you're still always viewing that,
that,
that barrier as,
as this is as high as we can go
in that.
In that sense,
do you think,
do you think of yourself or view
yourself as a part of this process?
One hundred percent?
Yeah.
One hundred percent.
I've always felt like I've always known
were speaking about Moitai where,
where the sport could go.
Um,
you know,
coming up,
I never thought I'd still be actively
doing it while it got out there and got
the exposure it's been getting recently.
Um,
but I always knew I would be a person
that helped it go along and that was a
huge thing that kept me from ever
venturing fulltime into mma or into
boxing because I was like,
there's only a handful of us doing this,
me and Joe Schilling and Tiffany and
Chi,
you know,
in a lot of other people.
I was like,
if I,
if there's only a handful of us doing
this at this level and going out there
and taking these almost impossible
fights and I leave who,
who,
who is there to do this,
who's gonna do this?
I'll be somebodies.
Got To go through the gate and get
bloodied up,
you know,
that first person that has to do it.
And uh,
I can't like pass this off on somebody
else.
I can't give up.
Like that's going to make it that much
harder for them.
So yeah,
I've always felt like I needed to be the
inspiration I wanted to see in the
world.
Do you find a great benefit and being
able to train with him?
Because
when we first started training together,
I will do it.
I'll get this adrenaline dumps when I
was sparring with them,
I was like,
oh my God,
like this is I'm sparring with Kevin
Ross.
And then slowly it will get better.
And like now we've become great training
partners and he's been a huge part of my
career obviously.
I mean,
yeah,
definitely.
Well,
you're the up and comer,
you know,
I mean,
and then of course you've got guys that
are coming up that are in the same place
that you were a few years ago and you
get to see it now that it is this sort
of long crazy chain of events in this
process that really,
essentially,
you only get a couple of decades out of
it if you're lucky,
if you're super,
super lucky and it's um,
it's such an unbelievably endeavor to do
what you guys are doing.
And I'm a fucking huge fan.
So to me this podcast was awesome.
I'm like a kid in the candy store.
I hope people got a lot out of it.
I really feel the same way,
man.
We were really happy to be here and you
know,
I've been wanting to do this for a
really long time,
so this is awesome.
Let's do it again sometime,
man.
Maybe when you guys are fighting,
we'll do a fight companion,
how some fights on and coming in and
then we'll talk some shit.
That'd be fine.
Uh,
your twitter is blah,
blah,
blah.
Last guest on,
but your instagram dream killer,
underscore Bolanos and you are the sole
assassin with the dea solis.
As in that's my twitter as well as my
instagram.
Beautiful.
And Combat Sports Academy.
How do they get ahold of your,
uh,
your gem?
Kiran?
CSA,
GM.
Every CSA.
Jim Everywhere.
Find it.
Google it.
You'll get there.
All right folks,
thank you so much.
We'll be back later tonight with Wim Hof
the iceman returns tonight at 8:00.
Bye.
Mm.